[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Laughter]
oh
no
hey
we have
uh thick as a dick
show for you there's so much to talk
about but before we do anything else
welcome
to fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i am
mark bernard yay
oh
uh man oh man i couldn't wait to get to
this show god there's so much to talk
about how are you good sir what are you
doing i am i'm i'm i'm feeling much
better okay last last time we gathered
here
together
um we you know we solving the mysteries
of this thing called life
i uh i had the covet
yeah you did
like that night that night after the
show i went home and took a test and was
like positive oh [ __ ] all right time to
wall myself into my home office and stay
there for like five days
um
but i have since made a full recovery i
am as out of shape as i was before but i
feel no worse than i did before
how was it how what
what was the worst of it
the worst of it was like because i'm i'm
you know double vaxxed and boosted
um the worst of it ended up being like a
really bad cold you know like
like brain fog a little thickness like
running nose sneezing like fever
all that [ __ ] for like two and a half
days i felt awful and then it kind of
coasted out then like this sneezing stop
the runny nose stopped i could think and
you know talk in full sentences again
and get some actual like writing done
um and by like the fourth day it was
just a matter of like when can i test
clear and i did i was able to regulate
by the by the fifth day
and uh
and then you know still still like kept
to myself because even though the
the sort of contagious period had passed
because they they say that the first
like two or three days of having it
you're the most contagious and after
that after you don't feel any symptoms
and after you test positive like you
could probably return to the world
um safe and knowing that you won't pass
it on to anybody else um
i didn't do that though like i still i
stayed in the house i stayed relatively
clear for my family there's no hugging
and no kissing and no not a business
ain't nobody kissing nobody here tonight
um
until about you know nine or ten days
out and then i then i left the cocoon of
the house and returned to the world to
be honest with you you occur to me as
the kind of guy there's not a lot of
kissing goes on all the time anyway
you're like wow you remind me of like
robert de niro in that boy's life where
he's like i don't like to see the face
jesus
put that bag on
that was one of the most haunted lines
from that movie man was him like i think
it was him about to have sex with alan
barkin she was trying to turn around to
him he's like i don't like to see the
face he's like this way or doggy style
that's it
um
i love you too kev
you look like a callous [ __ ]
uh hey you know who wants to kiss you
whether you got or not
uh my wife now that sounds hotter than i
mean it
so let me explain
please do that'd be great i i believe i
don't know if it was the last show or
the show before that you
dropped the recommendation
of the mads mikkelsen movie
writers of justice holy the [ __ ] dude
what a great [ __ ] movie that was
it's like
a legit great movie and i you know i
rolled it on her one night where i was
like
you know mark [ __ ] said this is a
pretty good flick and you know she
watches like a lot of crime programs uh
from overseas so she's used to reading
[ __ ] i was like you're gonna read the
movie
and she was like well she's like we can
always turn it off
[ __ ] five minutes in she was just
like this is great ten minutes in she
was like call mark tell him this is an
excellent suggestion
at the end of the movie she's like you
should have mark tell you more things
that you could do
i was like look not for nothing mark
didn't direct the [ __ ] picture he
just found it on [ __ ] amazon but what
a great recommendation that movie is so
[ __ ] good he is wonderful but the
whole [ __ ] cast and the plot of the
movie i've just never seen before yeah
well except that it's kind of the
punisher i guess you're rich
that's why i like it so much it's like
always the punishment but it's kind i
mean it is but yeah there's similarities
there i guess that's why
tonally it was great the [ __ ] the you
know the idea of using
static or statistics to be like
math using math to be like right you
think this is what happened
um the weirdest thing was i found it in
who under hulu and i have it categorized
as science fiction
and i kept on watching it like waiting
for the science fiction to show up but
then i was like oh well like statistics
is a kind of science and sure like
you're doing things with statistics you
can't actually do so it's fiction
science sure okay math fiction
every once in a while
chasing amy uh listed under science
fiction
and then i'm like what and then i
realized it's just like come on man it's
sci-fi to say that any man could make a
lesbian not a lesbian that's very
1997 sci-fi [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm sorry
i was a younger man then i didn't know
much
i wasn't i was uh that was dev
nice
sleepy kid um
we uh we have so much show
kids to get to i see a lot of folks in
in chat have been saying and on my
twitter feed um that they watched i got
to do an interview
with uh james gunn for like this little
thing we put together for hbo max like i
reviewed the [ __ ] the show piece maybe
we're gonna talk about tonight
and then they gave us an exclusive clip
to put in there and then i got to talk
to james for a little while and you know
it was like we only needed five minutes
it was only supposed to be five minutes
but james so gracious with his time we
talked for like a half an hour
so
they cut it up josh rouse dr josh roush
cut it up and stuff and turned it into
the piece that everybody is watching and
and digging thank you so much uh next
week on the show here
i think we'll have the uncut interview
because i asked james
and i was like they're only going to use
five minutes of this can i put the rest
of this uncut on fat man beyond he was
like absolutely totally so it was good
we talked comics we talked like snyder
verse uh we talked like everything it
was great it was a really great
discussion he's he's a writer
like you like a smart writer not a
writer like me who's dumb who's like you
know jay and sam but a writer who like
figures [ __ ] out and knows that one of
the most interesting questions or most
interesting answers was i was i was like
hey man there was one time
where like [ __ ] you had number one
and number two movie
you know at the box office you wrote
them both it was uh dawn of the dead and
scooby-doo were out at the same time i
was like you know did you ever conceive
of like this world now where like you
get to make whatever you want or
whatever
and he talked about
being that screenwriter as being like i
didn't i didn't like it
like he didn't like being just a
screenwriter because he's like i've i
loved the movies people made but it was
never what i
saw when i was writing it he was like it
was really hard
to give those scripts over even though i
was hired strictly to to write them he's
going like there's a you know he's a
filmmaker at heart we've seen his work
we know he's a visual storyteller at
heart so he's not and he's a writer at
heart too he's
the double threat right there
i thought it was crazy man that like i
thought he would have been like oh those
were the days [ __ ] like back to back
one and two and [ __ ] and he was just
like
that that was a necessary evil to get to
where i wanted to go it's really good
interview and stuff i could talk to him
for a while
um so i did that
uh this week and a lot of people have
been saying nice things so thank you
wait till you see the whole interview
and stuff he's so oh i can't wait lovely
yeah
um
all right we should we got so much to
get into
we do
you have any more chit chat [ __ ] did you
do anything else fun this week i i
didn't i've been writing comics and
we'll get into that later um but uh i
i've been doing this podcast we launched
relaunched the old podcast we used to do
called film school fridays and i used to
sit down with film school students and
and uh
and um
others but but never like this
incarnation of it for volume three
i just sit down with whoever [ __ ] you
pick a movie you love and we just deep
dive on it so the first episode we just
put up last week
was uh me and jake who works here in the
office
um
uh did uh licorice pizza and he's big
dpa fan so we did a deep dive on paul
thomas anderson i talked about how i
once like crapped on magnolia and
[ __ ] i watched magnolia again before
i watched licorice pizza and i was like
i'm i guess i'm more mature because i
this movie's beautiful and it's about
grief and loss i realized that when i
watched it when i was a kid i didn't
have any loss in my life and [ __ ] so i
was like why are all these [ __ ]
people sad and now i've lost some folks
and and some uh dogs and uh i know
i i related to the movie like far
[ __ ] more as uh my dog is dying in
front of me as we're watching jason
robards like die by inches in magnolia
it was the right movie at the right
[ __ ] time so in any event that was
episode one episode two
me
jake and luke from the office
did zack snyder's justice league because
luke is a massive massive [ __ ] fan
who vince like jake to watch and [ __ ]
and so i was like look let's [ __ ] i
can talk about zach all day long and
[ __ ] so episode two is that
um i know josh roush wants to do
down by law a jim jarmish film
so this is me inviting you
to pick a movie
like in my back of my mind like oh it's
dune but
but i'm gonna let you pick whatever it
is and then that movie like hopefully
that
artist has a career where we could jump
on the other things that person's done
but it's real loosey-goosey real [ __ ]
good times and [ __ ] all right i will i
will be the bonnet and put it in there
and i know you're around like i talk to
you [ __ ] enough
don't we do enough podcasting this is
like going to be a three-hour show you
want another two hours of my life i just
got over colvin
i it's funny i do have people who are
like hey man do you want to play like d
and d over the internet like we'll do it
on zoom and it'll be a great saturday
i'm like [ __ ] do you really want
me to sit in front of my computer for
six hours on a dad don't have to sit in
front of my computer for six hours
that is not a good time yes
why wouldn't you do that
um but i will 100 fun
good think of think of something so we
can sit down and watch together um
kids
none of the fun that we're about to have
tonight or any of the discussions would
be possible without a grant from our
sponsor and that sponsor tonight
is not the helena rubinstein foundation
this is not pbs
uh our sponsor tonight i look i knew
that pbs joke is going to make mark
laugh i knew it you did he's a high brow
joker he's a highbrow guy and he went
forward nice i want the tote bag and
everything
nice
the good folks at keeps uh are keeping
keeping the lights on folks if you want
to follow along with this ad
uh oh my god go to keeps.com k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man uh to follow along
and you're to receive the first month of
treatment for free
let's keep a eps.com fat man to get your
first month free man k-e-e-p-s
dot com fat man go there right now good
folks it keeps
um let me tell you something had they
existed when i was a younger man i would
have a lush head of hair i wouldn't be
wearing this silly ass [ __ ] hat
i'd be [ __ ]
i'd be paid and laid like that dude in
creep show too remember he's like this
hair is going to get paid and laid
that's who i keep that mark
if he existed when i was a [ __ ] boy
when i was watching creep show 2
if i had the ability to grab some keeps
and start working with it then
i'd be like i'd be like jon bon jovi at
circa 1986.
wow i was going vinnie barbarino circa
1978.
he had a lot of hair
young travolta just nothing but hair
sorry did you call him jan travolta is
that the one young sweden
i was in face off
i am the dancing queen
they've got
what do they call it uh [ __ ] um what
is it in loki a variant this is
comfortable to variant per continent and
yan travolta
so
as well
wow i'm not i'm i feel like
i feel like you're you're giving away
gold there i feel like you could you
could walk into marvel and be like
listen i want to do the variance
that's what we do here on this show i
learned from you give away fantastic
marketable ideas for [ __ ] free
that's what you do all the time
like you know it'd be great
uh star wars and you're like shut the
[ __ ] up that's a good thing
um back to keeps ladies and gentlemen
keeps offers a simple
affordable and stress-free way to keep
your hair man via convenient virtual
doctor consultations and medications
delivered straight to your door straight
to your door every three months uh you
don't have to even leave your house and
thank god because
omicron uh 24 7 care and support man
you're gonna get more out of them than
you get from some [ __ ] relatives in
your life
i should
i wouldn't like some care and support
[ __ ] you i'm going to keep yes sounds
like it came from a personal place i
don't know i'll have to deal with that
has a network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you
in making your hair goals
a reality don't be like me my air goals
are in the rear view man you can save
your future i'm telling you i'm like
john connor
or kyle reese coming back in time to be
like would you [ __ ] get the keeps
you're gonna [ __ ] want it because in
the future
[ __ ] skynet whatever hairnet that's
what it's called in that version
i'm on fire tonight mark low cost
treatments start at 10
per month and keeps offers generic uh
versions of the two fda approved
medications to prevent hair loss
treatment plans are affordable that's
the key here right typically you have a
cost of pharmacy prices if you're gonna
go to a pharmacy you're gonna pay way
more than you pay for keeps you even
have to go to the pharmacies because
i'll tell you right now i worked as a
at a pharmacy when i was a kid at bay
shore pharmacy and i judged every
[ __ ] that came in i don't care
what they needed i don't care if it was
life-saving medicine i was like oh i'm
judging you if it was condoms triple
judge usually judged highly um if it was
medicine for the gout i judged you as an
old person
so
there's judgment
at the farm
ain't no judgment at home
the magnum condom sir i don't think so
i looked them up and down i was like
prove it whip it out that's when i lost
the job but i appreciate your delusions
of grandeur sir
keeps has everything your hair needs
god how many times do i gotta tell you
that man
uh delivered straight to your door with
discreet packaging and proven
results man remember prevention
is key so true treatments could take uh
four to six months to see results so act
fast what are you waiting for we're in
january you want some like june hair
going and stuff bam like start working
now
uh when it comes to your hair
save more
and spend
less mark's gonna take us home take us
home mark if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-p-s dot com slash fat man to get
your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fat man
we thank the good folks at keeps for
sponsoring fat man beyond i just want to
shout out simon smith
on chat made me smile he wrote keeps
manscaped blue chew tells you everything
you need to know about kevin's
demographic
limp dick bald [ __ ]
i always think this show of like i don't
know there's teeny boppers sitting
around their tvs like the way they used
to watch dick clark
with their feet in the air doing this
[ __ ] oh kevin and mark are on shut up
everybody
but i guess it it's a it's it's true
that's who the our audience is reflected
by our sponsors man and indeed we are
the audience and they look like us
apparently
we came we saw we represented our
audience
um all right man let's uh now that we
paid our bills
so much so much and i'm sorry this is
gonna be gossipy and i don't normally do
this sort of thing normally i i
try to
talk about things that i'm just you know
happy about and [ __ ] like that
but this
we you know how do we not talk about
this i saw on twitter lit up the other
day
with a bunch of people being like
you and mark have to
speak
uh one of the biggest stories in uh the
great geekosphere this week ladies and
gentlemen if you will
um is an article that was in new york
magazine
um
about uh
uh joss whedon
the undoing of joss whedon i believe it
was called was the title of the article
um and it's uh
it is a fascinating read here there's
the
i saw i woke up that morning and i saw
josh whedon was trending
and ever since like age of ultron
when he's trended it's generally been
people like you know dog piling on him
remember during age of ultron they were
mad about the black widow storyline
that's kind of where it like really
started where the where the crown
started to slip so to speak and whatnot
so whenever he trends it tends to be
people like being
angry at him so i don't think about i
don't i don't engage with rage tweets
and [ __ ] like that
so i saw it trending
moved on
went and had a whole last day
night
came back
looked at twitter for the first time in
[ __ ] 10 hours
refreshed
[ __ ] still the top [ __ ] story man
like it would not
people would not stop tweeting about it
so
i i said all right i generally don't
engage with this sort of thing
i'm gonna read the article and stuff and
when i say i don't engage with this sort
of thing i don't mean that to sound like
i'm altruistic and [ __ ] better than
most
i i'm i'm insanely
um you know
self-interested so why the [ __ ] would i
read a whole article about some other
person you know what i'm saying
that's
unless they're scientists or teaching me
something new about covet but like an
entertainer unless it's an entertainer i
know like if it's ben affleck i'll
[ __ ] totally read that article and i
did and i was happy to see i was
referenced in the one he did an
entertainment weekly just recently um if
my kid does an interview i'll [ __ ]
read that but read about some other
[ __ ] dumbass entertainers ideas like
why i'm a dumbass entertainer it's elvis
if it's obvious if it's a new interview
with elvis then you'll read that oh my
god let me tell you something 31 movies
this guy made
don't get me started so in any event
did you see somebody linked to us on
twitter a trailer for what was breaking
the habit
i think um this old elvis presley movie
with sally field
as a nun who goes to work in the inner
city and so it's all about these young
women who have to like sort of they need
to see the woman not the nun and then
they'll accept the nun and so there's
like let's wear the short skirts and
let's get her hair done cute and let's
go and minister to the people and like
elvis is working in a soup kitchen
i think or maybe he's a hammer dasher
unclear
and
and i'm like what is this movie this is
insane i kind of like it
one of us one of us you know there's no
clambake
i saw
i saw a poster for when i was at uh
graceland for that movie and i was like
he was in a movie with sally field um
fascinating
anyway the undoing of joss whedon
yes so i read the article
and it's a long read and a good read i
know i saw on twitter a lot of people
were going after the
the writer layla i think her name was i
didn't commit the writer's name to
memory i'm sure somebody will say it in
chat
um and some people like went after her
as if like she was the problem in the
article but what i read
was an interviewer who was i'm just
gonna press record and put this here
now
and he just went
like
he didn't seem tricked he didn't seem
edited he didn't seem led down a path
he
he
seemed like he had a lot
on his mind
to say yeah it feels as if he thought
that this was going to be the chance
to both set the record straight
to admit to some things and then to
begin to reclaim the narrative for
himself
like i i think he was
led to believe either by
himself or by his pr people that this
was the beginning of the rehabilitation
tour there's i cannot imagine
there is a pr person involved in this
and if there is
that pr person i i don't you know i'm
i'm
i i
i
that is not a good pr person that walks
that person into that situation
unless that pr person sat right there
and
said every time he opened his mouth
leaned over and was like
um don't like say anything say the
opposite of that that was the thing that
was [ __ ] mind-bending it was like it
seemed like
he wanted to destroy any
goodwill
that was left and i know you were a
buffy guy i was not but like
it it was just like
time and time again
it was almost as if he was like i don't
want this career anymore so this is the
quickest way out of it he hasn't said
anything in all this time
and to break your silence with what he
said
is is just mind-bending to me and not
even as like a fan of pop culture as a
director
just as somebody who spends
a lot of time in the media talking
uh doing interviews doing podcasts
speaking my mind tweeting or something
like
if you felt those things
like even if in your head and heart
you're like she's from another country
man
why the [ __ ] would you ever say that in
an interview setting
even if in your heart of hearts you're
like i don't trust that guy and i don't
like that guy who made troubles for me
why the [ __ ] would you use the words
malevolent
bad actor twi like it was it was mind
bending like i i from a sociological
point of view i kept turning the page
going like no no there must be a butt
here
and it just kept
going further and further
down man like and it opened with
reference to like working with the
justice league cast
where you know we've heard from the cast
of the justice league in various ways
shapes and forms
um about their feelings
about working on the justice league
and it felt like he was like well [ __ ]
it i'm going to say my piece or
something
um
but so in the piece like the art
the author i don't i don't know if he
told this story or if she got it from
somebody else i felt like it was
from a crew member or something
that he said in front of everybody he's
like this is the rudest cast i've ever
worked with
like
on any number even if you felt that in
your heart of hearts you're the guy
showing up that like already the cast is
like i didn't sign up to make a movie
with this person like you got to win
them over nothing winning about that and
then even though the dude was like well
this is what i really said to gal gadot
even that was like bad because it's like
well what you're saying to the artist
who says i don't want to do this or i
don't want that in the movie
even if you're putting it comically
in you know 19 [ __ ] 10 terms
like it's still
you're telling an artist who is like i
don't want to do this and i have an
issue with this
well [ __ ] you you're going to do it
because that's my job like
all of it was fascinating to read i'm
you know there but for the grace of god
go i except for the fact that i i've
never treated people like that like i i
just my mother would die a thousand
deaths if she thought like that was who
i was and presented on set or in
interviews or something like that
i i was
confounded by the by the whole thing
i've not honestly i bet but then i was
like i've not read a lot of press like
i've never read i've never read a joss
whedon interview in my life so i'm like
is this standard like has he always been
this
candid and this is not even candid this
is just like
like
like all of it was like it's their fault
it's their fault it was this person it
was that person if you were gonna agree
to do that magazine piece in the hope of
[ __ ] like let's get back to where i
was or even back to work you needed to
say the opposite of everything he said
you needed to be like everyone's right
and i was wrong and i was a piece of
[ __ ] and
you know i'm hoping to change so you
know i'm sorry to this person i'm sorry
that person
that's the article like you do
this article he didn't need a publicist
for or even a magazine he literally
could have went online and just
spewed anger and stuff but man oh man
you could tell it's been building up and
[ __ ] i'm not putting you on the spot
going like as a [ __ ] buffy watcher
but you have more exposure to this cat
than i have had over the years and i'm
not saying like i don't know who he is i
know he's huge in pop culture but i
didn't i was not a buffy person and so i
never was part of the you know the cult
of weaving stuff has he always been like
this
well i mean
i think
and this is in no way a defense of
anybody or anything
but
there
there is the fact that he's a
uh
he was born a rich kid
uh
second generation third generation tv
writer i think
um
who who was sort of from his own
admission
was brought up in such a way
that that like you know withholding of
approval from his mother and all of that
stuff
you know was writing i was on roseanne
in his early 20s he was writing movies
by his mid-twenties he was running buffy
by the time he was 30. and so for a good
15 years at the very least here's a dude
for whom the world revolved around
you know everything he did everything he
said there were an armies of people
whose job it was to execute that stuff
now
there are some people for whom their
lives armed them with a different
reality which is
you know
i was poor growing up i learned to get
along with people growing up i learned
you know i was taught humility by my
parents i was all of those things i
think
it's it's the the you know absolute
power corrupts absolutely you know and
especially if it corrupts you when
you're young and especially if you think
it's owed to you
you know and so i think that feeling of
this is my life and i deserve to have it
and i deserve to have whatever i want be
that
you know
writers and minions and producers and
customers and everybody doing what i
want on my whim whether it's actresses
that are on my shows who i feel like i
owe it to them to sleep with them
you know like i i i would never have
been able to forgive myself if i didn't
sleep with these young women like that
was in the article
that's in the article like the the the
level of entitlement that comes with
apparently being john sweden that he
could have whatever he wanted whenever
he wanted it
um damn the torpedoes and you know as a
buffy fan you know and it's it's i think
less trenching and less tragic for me as
it is for
the scores of women out there who saw
themselves in that show
but then to realize
that even with what felt like feminism
even with what felt like female
empowerment was also the sort of
undercurrent this this top spin
of misogyny even still
you know and the the fact that he never
identified with
with buffy herself
but rather and i read this in a piece of
variety today
you know that he was actually the the
dweeb who was always next to the hot
girl who everybody always no matter what
thought was a dweeb you know he was a
nerd and he was a nerd who had friends
and he wasn't was there a character like
that on the show
absolutely xander was buffy's like best
friend who never she never gave him the
time of day you know there's never any
hope for a romantic relationship there
the brunette kid
yeah
like i've watched
before we we did jane salam bob strike
back like eliza dushku was up for the
movie and i i knew like
racing with the sun a movie she did like
years ago as a kid
but you know somebody was like don't you
watch buffy and i was like no and
they're like oh you got to watch her
episodes buffy so i watched the
helm hellmouth
yeah it was a season finale and she was
in like a couple of the episodes so i
have like you know and again it's like
you can't couldn't avoid it over the
last 20 years or whatever the [ __ ] so i
have a passing familiarity but
i did i in my head
that is
like i
who did who did uh seth green play
he played oz he played a love interest
he was also a werewolf
um of allison who were the boys in her
immediate clique
um there was oz who showed up i think in
the second season there was xander her
sort of like long-suffering you know
sort of best friend who was a bit
hapless a bit fumbly there was spike the
evil vampire
and there was angel the good vampire who
turned it to be a boyfriend who then
once they slept together he then turned
evil
that was the whole shebang um but
but like who he chose to see himself as
you know who he you know
what his avatar for that show is and
some of the hurdles and the trials and
the the the obstacles he would put in
front of buffy specifically um
in hindsight begin to reveal some of the
levels of his own
sort of psychosis and his his
perspective on the world and on women
and on power and all that stuff
you know it's it's a thing that i think
every generation has to have it's it's
it's bite at which is how do you deal
with art that you love made by people
that you can no longer start
you know and i think for a long time you
know people like woody allen is that guy
for me you know roman polanski is that
person bill cosby is now that person and
i think joss whedon is the latest in
that sort of
the work that he made when he was young
meant the world to me when i was young
and how do i reconcile the fact that i
want nothing to do with the guy but
still find value in the work
you know and what this article does is
sadly put a very very sharp point on the
reasons why
you know joss whedon has fallen from
grace um and those reasons are for the
most part entirely internal
never i've never read anything like it
like self-immolation
on that level where it's like don't
don't say that like why would you say
that well don't say that but that's a
bad thing to say good spoke is truth um
this is the like look the ray fisher
stuff
is bad any day for him to be like he's a
malevolent force and
that's
questionable terminology i know he likes
to use flower english but saying he's a
bad actor in both senses that's like
[ __ ] uncalled for and bad on any day
this article happened to drop on martin
luther king day which made it you know
even worse it amplified how how badly uh
it uh that
statement was thought of
put out into the world said
you know
the only malevolence i saw was in that
statement
like
you know and i'm not saying i haven't
ever like [ __ ] bad-mouthed somebody
in the press like of course like i've
said [ __ ] about
bruce willis and whatnot and
even though at the time i was like oh he
deserves it like eve now years later i'm
like i wish i just kept my [ __ ] mouth
shut
um this doesn't seem to be that case
this guy is not like i wish i could
maybe he's thinking that now i wish i'd
kept my mouth shut so the ray thing
is crazy and and really inexcusable and
[ __ ] deplorable
the gal gadot thing
is just in
nuts to to say like you know
well you know she english isn't her
first language like
what like
it's just nuts
even if in your head you thought that
it's like why would you say that man
it's easily debunked she [ __ ] told
the new york times she was like oh i
understood
perfectly
um
so that
that [ __ ] was already like [ __ ] off
the rails but the thing that like hit me
the hardest
was there's a story where he dresses
down a writer
in front of like a bunch of other
writers i don't know what show it was
but like the way they described that
they said he was like pretending there
was a projector and
slideshow and he put on funny voices
that the author said like was only funny
to him or whatever but
dressed a person down in front of
everybody else now
that that i mean look all of it's
[ __ ] bad but that [ __ ] is just
that's inexcusable wrong like that's
where
you know i i
i can't believe but i know it happened
the temerity to [ __ ] comet like the
world's biggest movie star
like you did with gal gadot i can't
believe the [ __ ] temerity uh that he
had
to say what he said about ray to cut ray
out of the [ __ ] movie to say ray was
a bad actor we all saw [ __ ] zac
snyder's justice league grey's great in
the movie
but the one that like
like hits me on a personal level
is like i'm a writer
and and i'm [ __ ] all that
do you know how hard it is to be
creative you know how hard it is to be
creative you know how hard it is to put
an idea out there man
you know it's it's a harsh cruel world
and to share a little piece of yourself
and i don't know which show it was but
like if it was buffy those shows seemed
like they had a lot of [ __ ] personal
angst that came from the writers and
[ __ ] like that i don't know where it was
from but
i don't care if it was from the most
topical or you know superficial show
any writer putting themself out there
man like you don't you don't [ __ ] you
don't do that i've not i haven't been a
show runner forever i show run once
on [ __ ] masters universe and i was
slobberingly
[ __ ] grateful for every syllable that
[ __ ] came through
did that mean that i accepted everything
no i would rewrite stuff or whatnot but
like i never [ __ ] told them you come
over here i'm gonna tell you what you
did [ __ ] wrong and i'm gonna do it in
front of all these [ __ ] people and
i'm gonna make a joke of it make a show
of it that [ __ ] like that kills a
[ __ ] spirit bro that will kill a
creative [ __ ] spirit and that
i found like [ __ ] so heinous that's
the thing that i responded to like
you just wanted to go back in time get
into like bust into that writer's room
and [ __ ] choke that dude up against a
blackboard and be like shut the [ __ ] up
man like you don't get to be this person
you don't get to like [ __ ]
mock other writers and [ __ ] like that
because you sit in this business these
people are writing your piece of [ __ ]
show they're taking your stupid ideas
and trying to make something of it you
[ __ ] lay down a carpet for those
people you don't [ __ ] make fun of
them and [ __ ] or take away their
humanity in front of their other fellow
writers that hit me really hard i read
that [ __ ] maybe it's because i was
blazed when i read it maybe because i
read it it was like midnight but i was
like i for some reason i was in the room
while it was happening and i was like no
no like you know like [ __ ] batman
where i'm like no and i just wanted to
do something that
there there's no excuse for any of it
man but that's like [ __ ] to kill
somebody's creative spirit and [ __ ] like
look
not
you know was grown up enough to be like
i called hr on this [ __ ] guy [ __ ] him
like she he ain't gonna do [ __ ] to me
but this writer who he dressed down in
front of people
probably didn't have that same like
self-assured
like snap same
uh
what do they call that [ __ ]
voice uh uh position uh you know agency
like
they don't get to do the big gal gadot
stand-up thing or even the
ray fisher like i'm gonna [ __ ] talk
about this in public thing that poor
person had to [ __ ] suffer silently
until that story came out and probably
still suffers from it man i remember
every [ __ ] time anybody said
something not critical i could take
criticism particularly if it's [ __ ]
helpful criticism and [ __ ] i take that
my whole [ __ ] career and [ __ ] but
somebody who like tries to tell you your
[ __ ] like you're not good at a [ __ ]
thing and they're better at it like
[ __ ] man that's
you know you only get to say that [ __ ]
if you wrote every [ __ ] script man
you don't get to dress anybody down
for [ __ ] ideas that aren't up to par
with you
get in there rework it but keep your
mouth [ __ ] shut like i'm sure
on some level you're supposed to like
make somebody how do you how does
somebody get better without criticism
ain't nothing wrong with criticism i
ain't saying that
but there's everything wrong with
[ __ ]
making pageantry
and mockery of somebody's creative
process that broke my heart and and made
me so [ __ ] mad and [ __ ] i had no skin
in this game
prior to that that suddenly put skin in
the game where i'm like well what the
[ __ ] man like
yeah there are some people who suffer
from a devastating case of never having
been smacked in the mouth
like
because anybody who had ever faced any
kind of adversity in the world would
know that you just don't be cruel like
and that's cruelty as as circus
you know and like why you would describe
as you mentioned
this is a person who had
forebears in the industry
you know what i'm saying so like
that person i'm not saying he got his
job because of his dad but like you have
a leg up if your parents are already
working in that same industry that
you're trying to work in otherwise how
does he [ __ ] get an entree into
roseanne i'm sure they needed somebody
young and whatnot but like somebody
knows somebody right like
yeah
and
totally and it and none of it is to take
away from his talent because he was and
he still is a wickedly talented writer
but he's getting in there
was easier than it is for most that is
what privileges that's the very
definition of privilege and for that
person to then be looking down their
nose at somebody who didn't get in as
easy
like that's even [ __ ] worse to me
yeah now there there's never a call for
that there's like
respect anybody who comes to help you
build your house
you know and give them give them the
common courtesy of humanity and be able
to like
walk away from the day
without having to go and cry in their
car
you owe them at the very least your
[ __ ] vocal appreciation out loud in
front of others at the very most
maybe a [ __ ]
or eat them out whatever the [ __ ]
thing whatever they got down there you
praise the people who help you make your
art man at all [ __ ] times you lay
down your coat over a [ __ ] mud puddle
because otherwise
you're [ __ ] alone you're you're
you're a person with ideas and that's it
like you ain't going any [ __ ] further
takes a village man and as i understand
it on shows like that when you got like
a big writer's room if you're cranking
out what they do like 20 episodes a year
like yeah
yeah there's no way to do it by yourself
and you know the job
although james gunn is doing it by
himself on peacemaker do you see he
wrote
all four episodes so far i think he
wrote all of them i think he wrote the
whole show
um is my understanding to be done
it can't like it's been done like you
know aaron sorkin wrote all but like two
episodes of the west wing in the four
years that he was on it
jason michael strzezinski wrote every
episode of babylon five but one you know
like it's possible it's demanding and
insane but it's possible don't you want
to know why strazinski didn't write the
one
because neil gaiman wrote that he didn't
write i was literally just gonna say
it would have to be because the other
guy is a genius and it's
that's that's a great bar trivia that is
fantastic bar trivia if you were ever
gonna be
at a geek bar like scum and villainy
this coming villainy cantina located in
hollywood on hollywood boulevard man
home to our very own banff man jc and
whatnot but yes that's kind of like
i knew he'd show up
you have a take on any of this jc do you
read that article i read some of it and
then it got kind of
gross and so i stopped reading it what i
wanted to know is mark you were a
journalist for a very long time did you
were you ever
interviewing somebody
where they said something that you know
in the moment that you shouldn't have
and how did like how is that journalist
reacting
sitting there listening to this guy like
is she salivating because she knows
she's going to be the biggest thing in
the world for four days or is it she
didn't have to like set a trap it wasn't
like like oh i had to catch this guy in
a lie she literally just sat down was
like what's on your mind bro
or are you like she's sad how do you
react when you're
literally watching somebody dig their
own grave and then you have to
you know you have to
throw the dirt on top of them the next
day
yeah i mean it's it's i i've never been
in that position because i was never
an interviewer very much like i did it
occasionally when
when uh when i couldn't resist when
there was a subject or a topic that i
really wanted to talk about but i've
edited plenty of stories in which
[ __ ] are just hanging
themselves out to dry
and it's it's always you know you're
you're a professional first when you're
sitting down opposite that person and
the difference between you you know
you're asking the questions you're
you're proving you did the research
you're you're posing
the quandaries and the issues to talk
about and when that person starts to
talk
you're hoping that they will do this
which is
reveal their soul to you you know and
you're hoping that you've you've created
a scenario in an environment that lets
them do that you know and and this this
piece by lyla shapiro i think that the
writer's name is
is in no way gotcha journalism it is in
no way in entrapment it is in no way
you know she offers him plenty of room
to explain himself she does her research
she also by the way seems like a fan or
seemed like a fan going into it
yeah like you know she had some
connection to the source material and
some previous connection to this guy
you know which is you know the kind of
person you want to do this you don't
want a completely unbiased person
because then they don't they don't have
any passion for the story you know but
she seemed like she was willing to
listen to this man explain herself
you know but the explanations were
personally i have to to imagine not what
she wanted to hear like i'm sure she was
hoping to hear the either apology to her
or the the real reasons that were
underneath what seemed like mania and
have those reasons be sympathetic
you know or professionally like dude
yeah go ahead keep calling yourself a
vampire who sucks the blood out of young
women like
keep going like
this this is gold
i mean if you're sitting there and
recording that interview
like when you get to the story of i was
five years old and i invited a friend
over
uh and then walked away from him and
then that friend drowned in a lake it's
like
i think i might have turned it off at
that point been like you
you may wanna
talk to him right
like yeah
yeah or like even for him like i think
lots of his stories were
i've been doing a lot of work on myself
a lot of therapy talking to a lot of
people i think i'm in a place now where
i can talk about these things
and even still would would like get up
and excuse himself when he thought he
said too much and then keep coming back
just man
excuse yourself sorry i can't do this
anymore yeah that's true um it was just
good
i'm just gonna say like some of the
shows a bit of a
a lot of it shows a lack of
self-awareness
you know a lack of sort of understanding
where you are in that process and
understanding
the reality of the things you're saying
and how somebody else would hear those
things you're saying and respond the way
many people in the united are responding
you know like it it feels as if this was
a you know prick of prick duffy nut
bleed
you know
that he was hoping would help some of
the other pricks in the industry like a
little bit easier towards
letting him back in the door
um in chat someone wrote named no one
said this um
oh man it went away here it is
uh rey has been trashing josh this
entire time when josh tries to defend
himself people still side with rey
whether josh speaks out or keeps quiet
he can't win this is not that
um
he was winning by keeping quiet if this
is how he was going to
to talk you like there is no defense all
he needed to say is like hey i i came
from this world
and i have some problems and i've kept
my mouth shut to work on myself and i'm
still doing that and when i'm ready to
say more i've got more to say
this sounds like it's day one and he's
still
like i'm i'm right here like there was
no concession
in anything he said no
yeah it it felt a bit like a he said she
said where he just kept on saying that's
not how i remember it and she kept on
offering volumes of proof
on the other side of that equation in
the form of quotes from people who
worked with him
you know
reported pieces about you know here's
here's the real story behind justice
league and here's what happened
like
and he just kept on saying stuff like i
don't remember it that way i don't think
i would have said that like but yeah you
did like
we we got people on the record saying
you did and
more than one source otherwise we
couldn't say that it was on the record
yeah it's either like i am ready to
apologize for the damage i've caused
thousands if not millions of people or
have nothing to say in which case there
is no cover story in new york magazine
and i just keep living in my beautiful
house in santa monica as the the an
incredibly well-heeled
you know hermit it's the thing it was
tied to nothing it's not like well he
had to do this interview in order to
you know satisfy the
you know responsibilities as producer of
x y and z he literally says in the piece
that he's got nothing to do so it's like
why do the interview a lot of people in
chat are like why are we still talking
about this um apologies it's news i mean
it happened two days ago but it's still
news relevant to the show and uh we were
more
i was just more like oh my lord like
that interview
he has a lot more work to do and you
know and it's miles to go
before there's a world in which that man
gets to work in hollywood again
um
because i just don't think that the
business itself
um
can find a way to make the money would
need to make
in the face of the scandal with cause to
put this guy back in the director's
chair
so it's it's he's it's not time yet
may will it ever be time probably i mean
mel gibson is working again
um crazy he just got cast in something
else this week
i saw yeah
you know and there and for a long time
that was a dude you were like you know
what never going to happen persona non
grata
but hollywood's great weakness is it
loves a second act
um and it loves to find a way to forgive
people that at some point it once held
up on pedestals
and so like yeah in 10 years from now
is there gonna be another joss whedon
thing
probably
probably
or it'll be joseph whedon because he
can't go by josh anymore
that was part of the story too his name
is really joseph and
he adapted josh
yeah anyway
there but for the grace of god
so forth and such that
um all right moving on
moving on talk about something
that makes people happy and it made me
[ __ ] happy
never
never
never
imagined i'd see some of the things
we've seen cinematically over the course
of the last few years
but amongst the many things that i never
thought i'd see
i never thought we'd see the god
conscious
represent
in the real world man that [ __ ] moon
night trailer
is astounding
like it it's just like just when you're
like i mean i know what marvel does i've
i got an idea of what a marvel series
will be
it's a completely different approach
a completely different cell
looks [ __ ] gorgeous looks insane
looks like an a-24 version of a marvel
show
uh maybe because oscar isaac's right at
the [ __ ] heart of it but my god
perfect british accent with a fantastic
british accent and the whole beginning
of it
like i forgot i didn't go
you know i i know my moon night but like
i'm more of a mark specter moonlight guy
so when they start calling him steve in
the beginning of the trailer
i'm like oh man what are they what and
then i forgot i was like oh he's got the
d.i.d he's got what is it so she's
dissociative identity disorder disorder
so marquez there's a there's mark and
there's also
stephen there's also
another one
so when he gets the cell phone call i
mean i wish we could just watch the
[ __ ] trailer but every time we show
anything they throw us off you don't
even so unfortunately me and mark have
to do it like old-timey 20s radio
where we literally have to [ __ ]
explain it rather than look at the
[ __ ] thing in a visual medium this
trailer review is brought to you by
patriot brand cigarettes
smoking if you feel good about america
good lord um so
he answers a cell phone
and then somebody's like mark
where are you what are you doing and he
[ __ ] has that panic look of like
what's going on
um the outfit looks [ __ ] phenomenal
i will look if they just wanted to do 30
minutes of him of pushing shots
where he kneels over somebody and beats
the [ __ ] living [ __ ] out of them in a
bathroom or any place
i'm there for that show but it sounds
like we're getting a lot more than that
and there's one [ __ ] flash in the
hallway he's way at the one end and at
the other end
his [ __ ] conscious man oh
never thought i'd [ __ ] see that and
yet we're gonna see it and it's a great
representation it looks like the one in
the comics it's not like well it's a guy
in a white suit it's like oh he's got
that [ __ ] weird skull head and [ __ ]
yeah like it i i would have been on
board
if it was just a show
with with oscar isaac as a dude who's
losing time who's got multiple
personality disorder who's like
the grasp on his life is beginning to
slip away and everything is starting to
unravel for that cut like that just
seems fascinating and then when you tell
me one of those personalities is a
[ __ ] superhero named mark spector
who's also a moon knight then it's oh
[ __ ]
we're doing this now
outstanding
sign me up
um it is uh
i was i was
in regardless i've always loved
you know [ __ ] uh moon knight
uh
the uh the idea of him as as marvel's
batman
but
i would say
far more psychologically complex
than bruce wayne
uh the fact that they're doing the show
like this is what i love about this
disney plus because do you think they
would do a whole mar the moon night
movie probably not
takes a lot to get a lot into two hours
origin story and that this origin story
is is
out there
but if you've got multiple episodes
you could do chapters or like half hour
45 minutes long you could tell a free
four or five hour story with this
character
you could really [ __ ] sell moon night
moon night could be so embraced and you
know the way that like boba fett was
always embraced by like people who knew
and fringe people and [ __ ] like that
cult figure and now everybody has boba
fett
same thing with moon knight moon knight
is about to take a big [ __ ] jump man
probably bigger than ant-man like you
never hear people being like i want to
be ant-man but [ __ ] that's because
ant-man don't like hover over [ __ ] on
a bathroom floor and beat the [ __ ] out
of them
but once you see moon do it you're like
oh that's all i want to be
is moon cause that would look silly
yeah
um i also love the fact that that marvel
seems to be now officially starting to
set up
you know this sort of darker universe of
characters this more street level
universe of characters
you know and so giving six hours to moon
night
lets you just drop that dude into blade
without even batting an eyelash it lets
you drop daredevil into blade without
even batting an eyelash
and like suddenly there's all these
characters that live kind of in the same
world
that's
that's me coming on my own face and then
it running
down my face oh my god it's like [ __ ]
look
i want i want the pandemic to be over as
much as the next guy but as long as
they're feeding me these [ __ ] marvel
shows and disney plus and star wars
shows
i'll wait
uh i won't but it's not bad
it's a good consolation prize
uh yeah somebody just said in chat uh
parade four four four four one of the
actors just passed away in moonlight the
french actor
um yeah gaspard
yeah
something i did in a skiing accident i
just read yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] sad it was sad man
it's incredible right before this
thing's about to he was on uh
hannibal i read um
of course numerous french films
including one with lily rose who i made
yogurt
um
uh big bucket of win there rest in peace
gaspard
uh i look forward to watching that show
man oh my god i look forward to watching
that show they got one of the greatest
actors working today
to play that character and to play a
very complex character like that ain't
wasting
oscar isaac man that's
nothing busy yeah that's that's using
that dude's [ __ ] talents too
insanely well
isaac or isaacs plural or isaac
well give me all the oscar isaacs i want
them all
how many you got i'll take everyone how
many variants how many oscar isaac
variants do you have
give me them all
um all right so moon knight trailer
uh moon knight gives one a reason to
live hope yes at least until march 30th
when it premieres that one is coming
yeah
i mean is that when i'm coming because i
will be
oh my god it looks so good how long
until i get them in the suit you think
um
i mean
until you get like a full solid great
look at the suit
the bottom of episode two
maybe maybe there's flashes of in the
first episode
if they tell it like you know
reverse order but they can't because
based on the trailer they're showing him
not knowing [ __ ] [ __ ]
right figure end of episode one he's
gotta meet conshu right
with standard reason
so i think you were right maybe by the
end of episode two he's in the suit
or if he makes him his fist maybe he's
just in the [ __ ] suit in episode one
bro
i love i love being this excited about a
[ __ ] television program that i have
nothing
it reminds me of being a kid man like
this is how excited i used to get about
laverne and shirley
i'm like oh lenny and squiggy are over
you think she's going to put on the car
to get in episode one
this is
yellow on it as i got about good times
when [ __ ] uh when uh the episode
where james senior when they have the
funeral and florida drops she's like
damn damn damn that's some fantastic
[ __ ] television right there
it's pretty damn good
yeah no thank you i've been working on
my florida
that's that's my one florida that i will
get by
i want to learn
um all right we uh um bam
yeah hey tell us tell us the tale
you saw something i didn't see it but
you saw it so about about moon night in
the trailer for moon night there's a
scene where he's like in a truck or
something and if you look behind the
head rest i'll put it up
uh
you can see
von d
and i don't think he's talking about a
tattoo artist in los angeles
kat von d
it looks like a a victor von d to me
could be
it could be better
or
or
dutch it could be a bunch of bad clothes
or it could be really good
it could be
mephisto let's be honest
it's always mephisto always mephisto it
was mephisto
that's the thing that's what nobody
seems to know um yeah i i was i was very
excited to see moonlight because i was
also not a big moonlight stan like that
is not that was not my book like my
passing familiar but like it was never a
what i said what the [ __ ] moon knight's
up to this month
wasn't my thing but uh but yeah i will
i'm i'm here for it
do you you know what i did not think i
would be in here for i did not think i
would give a [ __ ] about peacemaker
i didn't
yes is that right
i because i i was not a big fan i mean i
i was i was mildly entertained by by the
suicide squad but it was not like my
favorite movie of god it was [ __ ]
this year already um
and then did not think that that was the
character that i wanted more of um so i
was a little like i guess i'll [ __ ]
watch it and see what it's all about and
then that first episode and that credit
sequence
i was like oh [ __ ] we're doing a thing
and we're leaning into this character
and this character who thinks he's hot
[ __ ]
but is a complete and total mess
and watching him try to pretend he's not
a mess and then getting to learn why
he's a mess and getting to meet the
father who's the worst and getting to
see people around him who need him to be
better than he is
um you know it's the thing that it that
it gives me that suicide squad didn't
give me is a depth of character that is
what tv does that movies can't but we're
living with this guy and seeing all of
his problems and seeing the reasons why
he is the way he is
and and as a character study of this
sort of like
aggro dude learning the truth about
himself
here for it and it's fun as hell
i was so ready for the you know hey man
this is [ __ ]
dc's deadpool for heaven's sakes man he
gets to like curse and [ __ ] kill
people
i'm on board i had no idea the show we
were really going to get and uh i got to
see episode four which drops like
tonight
at like midnight
yeah here or three am
back east and stuff and episode four is
absolutely fantastic and shows you what
the show is absolutely actually about
it's a lot going on in peacemaker but
the scenes with uh john cena and robert
patrick in episode four
that made me go like oh
i see what you're doing mr gunn
it is
it's deep
he's telling a story i never saw told in
this genre
in the superhero sphere i mean that's
the thing it's like he's taking a
cartoonish action figure
and slowly giving him a soul
uh there's a haunting the ending of
episode four
has a really haunting moment with john
cena that like shouldn't be
anything but ridiculous
and yet it's really [ __ ] beautiful
and sad at the same time uh james like
has that keen ability to write very sad
people
um people who
are trying to mask
loss or
abuse like it's
he's turning the character human
in you know instead of just being the
jingoistic like i'll kill for peace at
any cost peace any cause even if i have
to kill people
and actually stripping him down like he
said to show you where he came from and
why he is that person
and
you couldn't ask for a [ __ ] better
leading man
than john cena he's funny
um and he [ __ ] looks the part he
looks like an action figure but
he
the the pathos the pathos that he's
pulling off the heart and the soul of
the character he's getting that too like
we knew he could do the funny and
suicide squad he's like uh if this big
beach was covered in dicks i'd eat all
of them you know for for justin for
peace um so we knew he could do the
funny parts but
what he's doing is
with with the human parts
is incredibly special that's before you
get to the to the team whole team's
[ __ ] interesting
um and and got stories and levels how
awesome is it
to see like amanda wallers continue to
influence on on the team
with
you know familial
[ __ ] connections
um
you know the the references to
that might doll man
reader lad
like you know never mind referencing
aquaman but [ __ ] referencing those
bringing all three of those characters
into the dc extended universe
my i i was like for anybody that was
ever like oh man zack snyder's
dc universe is too dark man it's like
this
just validates
like snyder's universe it's like you
could do so much
with these characters like you know zach
paints the way he paints very
dramatically but like
james is is playing in the same universe
you know in a completely different way
and giving the characters like a big
sense of humor and it still works to me
i was like this honors the entire snyder
verse like it made me think as i was
watching it like [ __ ] man if the rumors
are true that flash movie is about to
reboot everything
and it's like but yet peacemaker proves
that like
this iteration of those characters is
still
like viable like let it go like
keep it alive i don't know i it's i i
love it so much and i expected to like
it
i had no idea i would love it so much
they in episode four i mean never mind
this is a very tiny detail but he's such
a [ __ ] comic book nerd uh gun is
like the the the white dragon
is a not a creation of james gunn he
existed in the suicide squad he's in
like the first five issues five or ten
issues of the suicide squad there is a
storyline where they talk about the
white dragon is this like white
supremacist [ __ ] superhero and they
showed his outfit
like for one panel like his costume
outfit
and in episode 4 spoilers
in a few hours they at one point you see
that costume i was like
um but that's tiny that's just like
comic book nerdy detail the story he's
telling
between father and son
mirrors the story between
mother and daughter that's also
happening simultaneously
um i'm digging it man i'm
telling you [ __ ] take all these
characters
add grief
and
you got me like he's just making a human
drama this is a crazy human story even
though it's a big cartoon and [ __ ]
um
it's it's special i i'm i'm i'm in man
like
hbo max
killing it as far as i'm concerned and
then when i talked to james i was you
know talking about like
where it came from and [ __ ] and he said
like working with john made him go like
i couldn't [ __ ] do this for a long
time but he said hbo max came to him and
be like we want to do a series what do
you want to do
and i was like oh my god could you
imagine breathing that kind of [ __ ]
rarefied error where hbo max calls you
up and they're like we want to do a show
what should we do and you're like
i got just the thing
um yeah it's worth your while kids first
three episodes dropped on hbo max it
drops every thursday
on hbo max from now until the end of its
run james gunn wrote every episode i
think he directed every episode so far
i think so i think he's a [ __ ]
machine man and he's out there promoting
the show while he's making
another movie
right now guardian's [ __ ] three like
bamf
living the dream hey look who's here
it's banff man i got some uh breaking
news via my phone i have the james gunn
interview ready if we want to run it
yeah it's 32 minutes though
so do we want to run it at the end do we
want to save it
i mean there's there's the fat man
beyond special version of that
which can run tomorrow
after
the episode airs after people get to
watch it oh we could do that
um we can or we could look to chat
they're going run it at the end
run it at the end
so far there's a lot of run at the end
then there's one guy philip doggos kind
of messed up kev's talking about an
episode he got to see in advance of the
entire world and basically given a run
down the entire thing
did you feel i gave a rundown in the
entire episode mark
now you said there was a conversation
between father and son
spoilers
in episodes two and three as well uh he
says this is why marvel could never work
with him untrue marvel could never work
with me because i'm not talented enough
um let's see what people are saying man
the end the end they're like right at
the end yeah the end the end some people
say tomorrow but everyone's like run at
the end all right so we'll think about
either running it
uh somebody's going it's already on the
kevin smith channel not the uncut one
this is like a 25 minute version right
yeah it's 30 this one's 32 minutes the
other one is like 10.
yes the other one is and half of that 10
is me reviewing the show i think so
uh yeah we'll do it uh
we'll do it not but not right now we'll
do it either at the end of the show or
maybe we'll save it
to another show but look at that man
it's got [ __ ] in it it's got real
breaking news
yeah look at that real breaking news you
can break in any time banff man
news like that um all right
somebody's like do it tomorrow to get
huge traction why oh because of the show
hey that's [ __ ] smart who said that
i said that billy
that's what i said
i didn't hear it when you said it but
when billy reynolds said it in chat
he said do it tomorrow and get huge
traction makes the most sense
you're damn right billy reynolds
good for you billy
way to think inside the box the same box
i made next week it's going to be fat
man beyond with kevin billy reynolds
what happened to mark he's traveling
where
with the news from mark bernard
um all right man we uh we know
uh how much we love uh [ __ ] uh
peacemaker we know how much we love that
trailer
for uh for moon night
um let's go to boba fett but before we
leave [ __ ]
uh peacemaker
that opening credit sequence is so
[ __ ] fantastic
like and it kind of shouldn't be given
what it is but
it's this perfect encapsulation of the
show in that it's taking itself
incredibly seriously yes people are
doing the most ridiculous things
and it's with straight faces it reminded
me of a time like of childhood where
it's like you were forced to sit through
a [ __ ]
uh opening theme song now we have skip
buttons so you can skip if you want to
but how could you [ __ ] skip that
each and every time there's something
new to [ __ ] discover man so oh i love
that he's doing the lord's work man
james is such a
such a talented [ __ ] guy and that's
again
he made this right after he made suicide
squad he wrote it and then during the
pandemic and then [ __ ] went and shot
a whole series and now while he's out
there doing press for it he's making
like guardians three like
live in the the time of your life kid
indeed the risky business line
um
all right let's talk book of boba fett i
have not watched this week's episode but
i did watch last week's episode with uh
what many people online refer to as the
uh the uh mighty morphin power rangers
kids
because they had multi-colored bikes
i didn't bump into that i'm still
enjoying this boba fett show i dig it
very much and uh
it works on somebody who don't give a
[ __ ] about star wars man other than like
oh i saw it when i was a kid my wife is
loving the boba fett show
um but i didn't bump into that bike
thing like so many people online were
like what the [ __ ] this ain't star wars
i was like i don't know that's very
george lucas to have something that
looks like a 50s hot rod i mean remember
in the [ __ ] prequels like the whole
[ __ ] diner looked like those bikes
so when i saw it i'm like would i have
done it no but like it's paying off it
does what the whole [ __ ] show does
which is asks itself as dave klein told
us last week
what how would george do it
and that's what george would have done
so i didn't bump into that i actually
like the idea of like they got bionics
and [ __ ] like that they're cyborgs and
whatnot
um i was trying to think how many
cyborgs are in the star wars universe
four
oh i'm sorry you said lobot i thought
you said boba i was like what
lobot yeah he's a cyborg good point man
there's is he would you say he's the
most famous cyborg in the star wars
universe
like you know the protagonist
the thing is is there's precedent for
that right like you see luke's hand at
the end of empire
strikes back so i don't you know and
then again it's cyborg too
yeah
it's weird when i was watching it i was
like what a futuristic idea that i've
never seen in star wars but
you know he just basically i saw a
[ __ ] picture online a little meme
of uh like
an ad from the old [ __ ] star wars
toys in the 80s and it's two [ __ ]
kids
who are like literally having the time
of their lives they're like
like while playing with figures and
somebody wrote on it
dave filoni and john favreau writing
star wars shows
um yeah i liked episode three is that
the episode it was last week when i saw
it that was the is that the episode
where this tuscan raiders got killed
yes
or was that yeah
no i think it's
it was three i think it's three it's
very bummed out by that i was enjoying
the
the tuscan raiders storyline and uh i'm
hoping
although it don't match up like i'm what
i'm ho
i dig this show but
if i hope it goes anywhere
i hope it's like a coward of the county
kind of thing
where suddenly somebody's gonna finally
do something so [ __ ] heinous that he
goes back to like being just a ruthless
[ __ ] killer badass
because right now he seems very like
like cane and kung fu man he's just like
very balanced
very at peace and we haven't quite seen
why he would be
so at peace because you know all the
tuscan raiders getting killed i thought
would have made him snap and like
[ __ ] now it probably happened did it
i haven't seen four yet does he go after
the biker gang because that's why i
assumed
like he saw that symbol
and he stole the bikes from the biker
gang
and then if he saw the symbol where the
dead tuscan raiders were then in my head
i'm like well that's payback those guys
came for their [ __ ] bikes and
killed everybody including their
beautiful banthas
do you want to talk about four yet like
it's like 12 hours all you have to tell
me is this is that addressed in four
yes
it better be addressed because like we
got to the end of that episode i was
like
no payback what the [ __ ] so there better
be some payback in this episode
over to you mark
i i
i will say
i have no thoughts i have questions
um my chief question is
why does boba fett want to be the daimyo
of masaspa
like
why
you know i mean episode 4 you know not
to spoil too much but does go into a
little bit about his his mental state
and and what he's looking to do and the
reasons why you know he
give me a beer not to spoil again not
going to spoil
but
i don't know what's in it for boba fett
to be this guy
you know and what did why it means so
much to him to take over jabba's palace
where if
as his stated purpose in episode four is
he could do that anywhere anywhere in
the in the universe he could be the
person that he wants to be why it needs
to be here
um
and then why does he think he can do the
job since it seems to involve a lot of
just talking to people and sussing out
political landscapes
which does not seem like it's um a
natural fit for a former bounty hunter
you know like if you told me that the
former band hannah wanted to open a bar
dealing with the unsavory like yeah all
right sure i get it you're used to
dealing with you know thugs and
roughnecks
open a bar
why you want to suddenly be a politician
um seems odd to me
and then my last question is why
does he seem so [ __ ] feeble
you know i think we might have talked
about it you know in the first episode
or two reactions but in the mando
episode that that resurrects him
he takes on like a dozen [ __ ] storm
troopers with it with a gaffy stick and
here with his armor he's getting his ass
kicked at almost every turn
so i wonder why what was behind the
decision to sort of nerf this character
for the show
when the last time we saw him
post you know charlotte pitt post tuscan
raider adventures he was
a little thicker on the middle but still
incredibly formidable
um
though those are my questions that the
show has yet to really answer which feel
like if i'm in episode four of the show
and it's nine i'm well almost halfway
through seven i should kind of seven is
it
i i should kind of know
i thought
didn't dave say that he shut seven of
nine or
five of seven five whatever
that's your star trek coming out
um but yeah like we should know what
your main character's quest is and why
he's on it
um
and i'm also wondering why is his quest
not fine bring me the head of han solo
like
it's his fault that i'm in this [ __ ]
sarlacc pit it's not jabba's fault it's
not anybody else's fault but han solo
who i brought into this [ __ ]
hung out with with with boba fett for
reasons that are unclear and then he he
[ __ ] punted me into a sarlacc pit
why is that not what this [ __ ]
wants to do
i uh harrison ford's
old and erin wright is just hanging out
oh bro i haven't even thought of that
holy [ __ ] man that's a possibility isn't
it
i think what's weird damn what are your
thoughts i think what's weird with the
show
is
at the end of the first episode of
mandalorian we're like why do we
care what's this guy trying to do
and then
grogu baby yoda is revealed and all of a
sudden we're in it and we watch over the
course of two seasons mandalorian change
right he keeps changing and we get to
watch that over
almost 20 hours
in this show
they're telling the story of
why boba fett
changed from being a bounty hunter into
being
the unelected president of mos espa
concurrently with what is going on
so
if they had shown all the flashbacks
stuff to us as the first five episodes i
think we'd understand and care more
about
why he's not a bounty hunter anymore
for the back half
but as it is i feel i think it's really
disjointed you're like what does he want
well they gave us a piece but you don't
get to go on the journey it's almost
like it's
the flashbacks are season one and then
they're giving us season two with the
most vespa
gang of of mods
which is a play on
modifications and
their clothing and
you know style
um
so i don't i don't know i think it just
feels very weird like i don't i haven't
caught up with why i care about what
boba fett's doing yet
which hopefully by the end of seven the
flashbacks will catch up to the current
day
i um i'm a less demanding audience
member
he was just happy to watch a guy wear a
costume
so
everybody
there are long stretches where i'm like
put the helmet on put the helmet on put
the helmet on i don't like to look at
the face i don't like the look of the
face put a helmet on i get all mark
bernard didn't like i'm like i don't
look in the face
don't show me that face
um yeah i'm digging the show but i
haven't seen episode four that's what
i'm doing when this is over i'm gonna go
sit down with my wife
and
since we're in our 50s we're not gonna
[ __ ] we're gonna watch fat we're gonna
fat we're not gonna [ __ ] we're gonna fat
[ __ ] that's for 20 year olds we're
50. we're going to fat
and there's an awful lot of tamora
morrison just saying things like i am
boba fett i am boba fett i am boba fett
like it's it's a bunch of different line
readings on those three words which it's
fun for a while and then usually but
and i and i still reiterate my my
statement from last week
or two weeks ago this show is in dire
need of a baby yoda
and shows in dire need of a thing for me
to care about and it's not yet boba fett
and it's not yet fennec shannon no i
thought it would be the the tuscan
raider kid i was like well that would be
interesting like if that kid was his
lodestar and [ __ ] like that he's doing
it for that kid or i gotta rescue that
kid but that kid got [ __ ] killed
like everybody else man
that was nuts not since
anakin skywalker have we seen a boogery
of tuscany
i uh i actually like every time he says
i am boba fett because that was one of
his like four lines from the cartoon
from the holiday special so every time
he says it and then in
episode three
when he's talking about writing the rank
or he's like i've ridden beasts three
times this size i'm like the the one
from the holiday special that you wrote
that's bigger than a rancor
like those were my
like geek out moments where i'm like
you're talking about when you were a
cartoon and not a person
that's and that's enough isn't it like
why does it have to be any more than
that why does it have to [ __ ] save
the universe
or cure [ __ ] covid like
can it just be like right on man
somebody's we're watching some [ __ ]
play with star wars figures same way
that people like sit on twitch and watch
[ __ ] play video games i am more than
content to watch john favreau go like
smashy smashy blah blah blah blah blah
blah
[ __ ] good times and every once in a
while if you drop me some like [ __ ]
nugget from the past where i'm like huh
you know
[ __ ] even more the better and [ __ ] so
i ain't that judgey
the other thing that's interesting about
this show
which
we didn't even really get in the
mandalorian because we got baby yoda
immediately
is
no forced users at all up to this point
like nobody no no talk of jedi no
lightsabers no force no anything at all
in this show
which i think is interesting i mean
rogue one was the only other thing that
was
kind of similar and then we got vader
doing his thing at the end but there are
no
didn't rogue one have that guy who was
like the force in iowa one
he's more sensitive and i think he's a
force user yeah they spoke of it kind of
like a religion listen to this [ __ ]
listen to this subtle distinction and
[ __ ] like that
distinction without a difference is what
you're saying yeah
um he's a blind dude dodging [ __ ]
laser blast
yeah he's either daredevil or jenna that
happens every day
the other thing i was very excited about
which danny trejo has done very very
many
projects yeah we didn't talk about triho
with the rancor man [ __ ] how awesome
machete in space i'm going to i'm going
to finally
get a danny trejo action figure
like think about like that if book of
boba fett does nothing else we're going
to get a bad ass danny trejo action
figure and i don't know did they make
machete figures did they make
you know figures of anything like
characters like mcfarland probably has a
machete figure um but it was never like
go buy it in [ __ ] kmart yeah spend
100 bucks on it never mind that he's
he's about to be
the most famous rancor keeper
in the history of the star wars universe
he already has the most lines for any
rancor keeper
but i thought it was a real sweet scene
to show him be like you know they're
very sensitive animals and stuff like
that because
you know we watched return to the jedi
when the ranker gets killed the ranker
keeper is like and you know it was
always kind of like a joke but
him talking about
the rankers like he's he's a i think
danny trey was a big pitbull guy as well
and it was almost like they were talking
about pities man where he's like look
they're known to be tough and blah blah
but they got big hearts
i did see somewhere somewhere on
instagram or maybe tumblr
it was a uh
a t-shirt which had danny trejo's face
in the middle and they said trejos tacos
trejos donuts trejo's rancors
already already all ready
um yeah he's absolutely [ __ ]
wonderful that is something when i saw
him pop up i was like well that is
something that boba fett and clerks 3
share in common
spoilers for clerks 3.
i might have
i might have been smoking a little too
much
i'm sure we can just edit that out later
on um
yeah man i was i was happy for him
you didn't see a thing
i was happy for him to see him in star
wars though [ __ ] that's awesome he's
uh
he's the one rodriguez pulling in the
homies
that made it warm too the whole thing i
was when i saw him pulling up i'm like
come on of course he's here
it'd be rude not to
uh in chat hyperloop says neca makes
danny trejo machete action figures
and now we know but now you're going to
get them the way that jc wants them
dressed
yeah now they can go on my sail barge
that i bought two years ago exactly
um
all right man [ __ ] we talked about uh
boca boba
we talked about
moon night we talked about
peacemaker
we talked about
that new york tweeting article
so
i guess that's all of our
[ __ ] we should dive into the news no
we can do some news we also got some
lists to cover we can do whatever yeah
let's do the list man you got a list i
got two lists pick one of them
pick one list
um
all right i'll pick i'll pick the first
one and if we have time at the end we
can loop back around maybe if chad wants
to know the other list we'll tell them
that's true wait a second what is
one list is your top ten right yes
that's a whole last discussion save that
for next episode right okay because we
probably won't have like [ __ ] 20
minutes of new york magazine to talk
about next week
what is your second one your second one
was about what's coming it's the 2022
movie calendar of [ __ ] we'll care about
let's do that let's do that next week
kids mark will tell you his favorite
movies
of 2012 this gives you [ __ ] one more
week to cram some [ __ ] i know there's
still a couple i haven't seen yet
um
excellent okay cool so 2022 will bring
us in chronological order
moonfall
oh [ __ ] the roland emerick movie which
looks like
uh the the
unintentionally comedic version
of don't look up yes
right like something's hurtling at the
earth that's going to kill everybody
yeah or i think if if i if i've if i've
parsed the trailers correctly
something has been living inside the
moon all of this time
and is now erupting like it's some kind
of egg and is now sending pieces of the
moon towards earth to be followed by an
alien invasion
and yeah you couldn't keep me away
i mean think about that that's the guy
going if you're not killed by the
falling moon
the aliens will get you
really double downing man
good for him
i appreciate that at this point he's got
like a disaster card catalog and stuff
pulling [ __ ] cards out like what if
it's this plus this great aliens plus
[ __ ] armageddon done he can continue
playing disaster mad libs for as long as
he wants to um i'm always happy to see
i'm always cheered
to see a roland emmerich trailer because
i'm like look at him man god damn it
he's who else is competing with him you
know what i'm saying who else is like
i'm the disaster guy yeah and the thing
that i always appreciate about his
movies is there is almost never putting
the genie back in the bottle
like when the [ __ ] happens it happens
for real when it's 20 21 or 2012
whatever that movie was and it was like
the tides are shifting the magnetic
poles are like no we're flooding the
earth yeah after tomorrow everything's
frozen you know like i'm never going to
not do the thing so yeah the moon's
going to hit the earth and then we'll
just have to deal with it
um
who's putting that out
i think it's like stx
or something that's let me tell you if i
was in charge of studio they get out
half that sentence and i'm like done
done here's a 100 million dollars
go make this movie
all right what's next
on february 18th uncharted starring uh
young tom holland
as
nathan drake
um i've and that's based on a game i've
never played that yes um there's been
there's like four uncharted games i
think
um which are all super fun they're just
like high adventure it's all indiana
jones basically treasure hunting and
running and jumping and leaping off of
tall things and puzzle solving but as
tom holland is as drake and it's um mark
wahlberg
as his sort of like old man handler
and they're pummeling off as [ __ ] diving
on a plane searching for forbidden
treasure in jungles and
it looks like a romp it looks like dude
tomb raider and i will still go see it
because i like young tom hollow
i like to see him spread his wings who's
who's putting that out do i get to watch
that at home or no
no that's sony
i think all of these movies coming out
you will not get to watch it at home
really i think i think so even with
omicron and [ __ ] people are still going
to force us out into movie theaters
i think i think the wrong lesson might
have been learned from spider-man which
is
if we think we have the goods
people will come out and risk a pandemic
to let us make a billion dollars
um
did you see the opening you see the
opening sketch of snl this week
their version of biden who's played by
that guy who also does a brilliant job
um he was like uh
don't stop seeing spider-man that was
the catchphrase
don't blame it on me we're doing our
best just don't go see spider-man i'm
seeing spider-man oh it was really fun
if you haven't seen the kids go watch
the cold opening of snl this week um a
lot of a lot of spider-man no way home
jokes
indeed
um
on march 4th we get warner brothers is
the batman
march 4th
and that's not a and also on hbo max
that's straight up theaters
straight up theaters look i'm there for
that one i don't give a [ __ ] if they're
like uh there's a new thing
and it's and it's called [ __ ] [ __ ]
kron it ate your ass
megatron you know what i've had 51 years
of that [ __ ] i need to see this
version of batman
that's when march what early march march
4th yeah early march when is moon
moon night is march 30th
in one month we're gonna get [ __ ] the
batman and moon night
yeah
crazy right
i know that everyone's like always like
what a [ __ ] horrible timeline we live
in
sometimes but then sometimes you're like
what an amazing [ __ ] timeline we live
in man especially don't do our homework
yeah really
on april fool's day we apparently may or
may not get morbius a living vampire
another sony picture
another sunny picture which
hey i guess we were gonna get it at some
point or another so
april fool's day is just as good as days
in
um may 6th doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
january february march april may
may four [ __ ] months from now we get
to see wanda again
wanda vision still remains my favorite
uh
marvel disney tv show
disney plus tv show um
and like i think one of my favorite if
not my favorite thing from all of
2021 i think might be my favorite piece
of art media i [ __ ] love it so so
much it is so it is grief porn and i am
there for it
and they're wearing [ __ ] costumes
like what's [ __ ] better than that and
it's fun
and and kind of
brilliantly creative in terms of like it
being a tv show within a tv show and
stuff oh
i absolutely love that so i look forward
to seeing
wanda again like a like a old friend a
family member that you actually like not
one of those [ __ ] family members that
you're like
but somebody like well i want to see
that cat again and i i've i've seen
online you know people are like uh she's
a hero she's a villain
i i hope she's the bad guy that would
rock for me
um yeah but you know but a redemptive
one and [ __ ] you know like don't don't
throw her away that's a great character
but she would of anybody she would be
excused if she went [ __ ] totally
rogue man i mean we saw the whole
[ __ ] ant show
he has reasons
and
as the kids although i did like that in
the in the trailer that was the the
post-credits scene it's like are you
here about west vale he's like what
happened in west vale he's like that's
not about west vale it's like but i
thought you were gonna come and give me
some [ __ ] over it nope i got other fish
to fry
that [ __ ] kid made me tear the
universe open and whoops
um do you see what doc doctor strange
did something i never could he just
dismissed wandavision
westvale where's that who cares um
somebody in chat said over no way home
it's tough
i love no way home as well spiderman
away in terms of my favorite thing of
2021 did that happen yeah i guess it
happened with the end of the year no way
home come out
yeah um
those two are neck and neck uh but i'll
be honest with you like
you know
yes there's definitely some grief of
course in
spider-man no way home but um
i don't know the grief and wanda vision
spoke to me
that was way into that um but anyway hey
man don't
let me like the [ __ ] i like
that's gonna be
the name of my next book mark let me
like the [ __ ] i like
and other thoughts
of on fan
and other fables by kevin smith
um june 10th we get jurassic world
dominion
the return of chris pratt the return of
sam neil and laura dern don't be online
that day every time a [ __ ] dude
breathes everybody's like you [ __ ]
and they attack him and [ __ ]
so
this movie would have to be
uh maze balls in order for people to not
attack chris pratt yet again online but
so i'm gonna stay off the internets that
day because i'm gonna go enjoy me some
dinosaurs and stuff i don't give a [ __ ]
who to humans are give me dinosaurs i
like where they've been going with this
iteration of jurassic park is this one
like planet of the apes where like the
dinosaurs have just taken over
completely that's what i mean i
i [ __ ] hope so like
enough with this human [ __ ] like i
want to see
machine guns yes that's what i'm
thinking
i hope the multiverse of madness gives
us cadillacs and dinosaurs that's what i
want
deep cuts bamf all
driving the cadillac
see
family
jeff's kiss look at that he dropped in
dropped science and got the [ __ ] out
class that's a real george stanza move
right there
very much so um one week after that on
june 17th
light year
the pixar movie about buzz lightyear
with chris evans playing buzz lightyear
i look way forward to that but somebody
in chat and i don't know if this is true
eli brand says the batman will stream on
hbo max starting april 19th 45th 45 days
after the theatrical release is that
true i mean the the window is short i
know it is at this point but yeah a
month and a half month in
yeah a month and a half
i mean but spider-man no way home ain't
even out in 45 days is it
nope
i don't know if i was them i wouldn't
commit to that i'd be like let's see how
much we can get at theaters because
they're talking about coming out in
march most of this kron stuff should be
on the wane somebody in chat was like i
wish i could watch a comic book show
where they don't talk about uh covid
like we're not it's not a topic but like
where you been man like it affects us
all we're not politicizing it we just
mention it and [ __ ] like that
um so yeah i i i looks like the cron is
down trending at the moment
uh hopefully if the news is to be
believed
uh which means that by march
you know nobody going to be scared to go
to a movie theater um
i would wear that
i'd leave that open i wouldn't make it
45 windows but that's me what do i
[ __ ] know i'm not good at the job
we've proven that before what about you
bamf man what do you got to say i was
just gonna say if it's down trending we
might be able to do in-person shows soon
too maybe we'll get there
marketer right there there's a
[ __ ] who's like how can i turn
this conversation to me and mine
and we love doing this show at that bar
so hopefully you feel like what
mid february
i feel like mid yeah like a valentine's
day-ish
timing hopefully if we keep moving in
the right direction
come get shot by cupid's arrow and
[ __ ] a full dose of omicron
oh you should just you should give up
boosters at the same time come get it
come get a needle in the heart and a
shot in the arm
all right so hopefully mid-february
we'll be getting back to do this
i also think like most movies make most
of their money
in the first
four weeks of release agreed um and so
like it honestly doesn't bite them in
the ass that much
if they give a month and a half to
theatrical and then like if you love the
movie like the only people really going
to see it in that last few weeks of the
release are people who are seeing it for
the second and third times and they were
going to do that anyway
um
so maybe they're they're not leaving
that much money on the table at the end
of the day
fair enough um so yes after light year
on uh june 17th on july 8th
we get thor
love and thunder
july so january february march april may
june
half a year from now
half a year from now that's gonna be the
sweet bomb for the soul right there i
love me some chris hemsworth and i love
what taika is doing with [ __ ] thor
like
give me nine
man oh i can't wait [ __ ] that sounds
good what else
um
july 22nd nope
the latest film from jordan peel
um
i don't know what the [ __ ] it is i don't
know what the plot summary is there was
a release of a movie poster which i
think was like
the tail end of a kite going up into a
cloud on the dark horizon like it might
be like an alien abduction thing
nobody knows all we know is oh hey
she's that's what she got interested she
was like nope
what's that
no
she's like i love jordan appeal uh let
me tell you something they don't they
don't even have to show us a trailer or
tell us what it's about they could put a
poster just says jordan feels nope
and i'm there man he's got all my trust
um
i loved uh you know um
get out um and and i thought the second
one us like
even though some of it i was like what
was still really like great and
interesting he's got a
big old brain man i like his writing so
i i mean they could put out a poster
with a [ __ ] kite on it and i'd be
like
i'm sure into that picture
yes i am the opposite of nope i'm yep
and i will be
see that's a better second draft was
better than that
a week after that on the 29th black adam
right on man the rock fire this stream's
gonna come true he's been wanting you go
have fun he's been wanting to make this
movie for so long he believes in it in
such a big bad way that he's even sold
me on it and as much as like
black adam's not a character that i
really
had much interest in but
his passion for it has made me go like
right now i got to see this movie
yeah
that's power balance in the dc universe
that's theaters only
um
on october 7th
spider-man across the spider-verse part
one
that trailer's good man and part one
makes you so happy because it means like
you just wait a minute and you're gonna
get another one a couple months
um
can't wait to see where they take the
character now i saw the trailer so i got
a general idea but i i think that's
scratching the surface i can't wait
yeah another way for it
a month after that on november 4th the
flash
the flash is november 4th
yes we've got
[Music]
10 months to the flash
indeed
i i i i'm in
i'm in
i i look forward to this flash movie uh
in a big bad way um because uh i you
know i love
uh bat fleck
obviously cast him in like 100 movies
but as a you know for somebody who's 51
who
you know
wants to feel like a kid again
seeing my
[ __ ] batman from age
you know 18
when that when that was my batman
be batman again is going to be a lot of
[ __ ] fun
yeah
a lot of fun i make no apologies for
loving michael keaton batman
nor should you
you don't have to i wish they would make
i wish that if you listen to episode two
of
film school fridays we have this
discussion about the snyder verse where
essentially i was just like just give
him [ __ ] 100 million dollars and tell
him do whatever he wants on hbo max once
a year
like
why not keep it going ah go listen to
that episode you'll hear my thoughts
anyway next
next week after that on november 11th
black panther wakanda forever what
that's happening this year
yeah
wow man
jesus like this is the [ __ ] year
20 years
and we don't even have a date for clerks
three yet but that's also so
that'll slot right in
um
this a month from there december 16th
aquaman and allah's kingdom
that's also this year that's also this
year i mean granted all of these dates
are you know
they're on the calendar but nothing is
set in stone
and is that it
uh there's one more
same day
december 16th
the long-awaited avatar ii
um i'll see it but i'll probably
i'll probably see aquaman first
yeah um i i still don't believe we're
gonna see i have a target yeah and also
like i i you know pull this leg and it
plays jingle bells i've heard many times
about
avatar too so i'll i'll believe it when
i see a trailer that date seems to move
all the time yes you know and especially
the later into the that calendar the
more the it's i'm not even saying likely
possible that those movies can shift
into 2023.
uh in chat they said nope disney changed
the release date of black panther 2.
to win
according to them well now you're asking
for helpful information
who did you think we were going to get
that
we just got critical information
um
i don't know
but you know they had to shut down it
and shut down for like the last two
months
yeah well or because she had didn't
latisha have a broken something
she did
um
i'll fill in while we're
fact checking black panther
uh
announced
today i believe
the rings of power which is the amazon
show
will be coming out
in the fall
do you have skin in that rings game you
like those those books i i
read the books at the beginning of
the quarantine
i i like the first three weeks of
quarantine i sat down i read all the
books
uh
um
but
i really like the movies i've gotten
really into the movies as i've gotten
older um
and uh
been through some more life things i
didn't like them when they came out
mark are you a rings reader you were a
rings reader right
i was uh i was it took a while for me to
get into it because i love the hobbit
and lord of the rings is many things but
not the hobbit um
but i do i love the movies more than i
love the books but i do quite like the
books they're dense
but i like them uh point being i got no
skin in the rings game uh i was not into
the books and i saw the movies but you
know i was like oh those are [ __ ]
huge but that was about it
stories and characters are they're just
not
they just don't do much for me and stuff
uh that all being said you guys are seem
like moderate to too uh strong fans
is that title
rings of power
like doesn't that sound like a porn to
you
i mean everything can if you wanted to
what uh what i mean is that an
expression from the books it's the idea
oh go ahead yeah yeah it's it's there's
there's a a a preamble i want to say
it's low of the rings where they explain
where the rings came from yeah you know
and there's a whole you know i think
gallatrial pete blanchett says it in in
the two towers
but it's you know seven rings were
welded for the elven lords and five were
for men but one ring the ring of power
to rule them all
like so the ring of power as a conceit
is part of it
i think it's adorable how you were like
you said it word perfect you're like or
something like that
i
it's
nine for men five for dwarves three for
elves just so that the internet doesn't
beat us up because we don't know lord of
the rings yeah
um as as to our original point black
panther wakana forever's release date it
initially was supposed to be released in
august
the shift was to november 11th
um
now it could shift again because there's
been a delay because of of leticia
wright and because of omicron
but disney has not announced a new date
for it as of today
uh they're pointing out in chat two
other movies which i don't think have
dates yet and that's why they're not
being mentioned on mark's list uh
scorsese's killers of the flower moon is
also happening in 22 2022
as is baz luhrmann's elvis movie which
we have seen a little teaser for but
those don't have dates yet so i think
that's why they're not on the list also
we know that historically mark
up until this episode has not been an
elvis guy and then revealed himself
uh listen like i
i love the fact that in almost every
elvis movie
the hit song it's just him singing the
[ __ ] title
what is it clan bank no haven't
clambaked i gotta win that race
um what a great year to look forward to
kids
if you're ever like oh this whole world
sucks
every one of those movies is a reason to
stay above ground
love too and family whatever the [ __ ]
but like
those are that's a good list of movies
right there man that's not bad yeah
that's that's [ __ ] worth staying up
for so
[ __ ] a man you're gonna have to kill
me to get me off this rock because i
want to see every one of those [ __ ]
now that's not an open invitation
over you
[Music]
some more tv shows
uh critical role i believe comes out
this year that mark had it comes out
this month it comes out in
like three weeks
uh it's the dungeons and dragons
uh
podcast that got huge that did the
kickstarter that yeah all those episodes
were finally happening yeah yeah the
first three having dropped in i want to
say it's january 21st but i might be
wrong about that but it's in like three
weeks um
i wrote an episode yeah
um
obi-wan
mando season three
bad [ __ ] only one is 2022 yep as it is
and or andor
and
i'd be remiss if i didn't say another
movie that
i believe is coming out in 2022 i hope
would be clerks iii
of course of course we don't have a date
for it so i can't we didn't
yeah
but i've heard the you know fall so
yeah i mean there's a whole list of tv
shows which we didn't get into but
she-hulk and secret invasion and endor
and obi-wan
secret invasion is this year as well
secret divisions here ms marvel is this
year
this could be the best year of our lives
just based on what's on television in
the movie theaters
never mind whatever personal joy we can
scrape out of life with others who we
may love like
these fake stories are going to keep me
alive
yes they will
except for that elvis story that's 100
true you know this [ __ ] guy made 31
movies in a very short amount of time
he's
busy
they say he was the king
all right so that's 2022 that's what we
got to look forward to uh thank you mark
for pulling that list together man you
wouldn't have that list if it weren't
for mark and thank you to the audience
for being critical about that list as
well
and trying to poke holes in it which i
appreciate
still mark's joy
why didn't you mention this movie well
it's non-genre so i don't care for this
particular
um we got news man we got something down
the guy who [ __ ] used to work the
news beat and [ __ ] man like a [ __ ]
jimmy breslin kind
and then one day
yeah that's right and then one day deep
cuts and then east coast deep cuts and
then one day he says to himself uh i'm
going to go out to the pic i'm going to
write the pictures i don't want to write
the news no more i want to write the
pictures and he came out here and he
started writing the pictures but
you could take the newsman out of the
newsroom but you can't take the news out
of his soul
mark bernard went and hunted down the
news that we're going to talk about this
week here's now mark bernard with the
news
news
um
hey
well you were a quantum leap fan right
you seem like that guy ish i didn't
watch every episode but i saw a bunch of
them and stuff uh i i was a big dean
stockwell guy
not that i don't like the other guy but
like dean stockwell you know [ __ ]
pretty magical dude
i liked his performance even before like
you know blue velvet it was just like
that guy's
he's got something he's got that moxie
yeah he does he's i liked his
performance i i will say about the other
guy with the show though i always wanted
to make a vampire movie called scream
bacular scream
your director now you can make those
dreams come true scotty i got a picture
for you
it is
exploitation but you're a white guy so
that's just a vampire movie called
screen baculoscreen
he had uh quantum leap and then years
later he had uh star trek right
yes yes star trek uh users two pop
culture pen tent poles indeed he's had a
career of many other things but those
are the two and now he's on like ncis or
or
one of those
cbs procedurals that will make a man
rich and never need anything else for
the rest of his life so what uh uh
hi
mark
what news of of quantum leap what hoe
from the front uh quantum leaps uh long
rumored return has taken a big leap
forward
nbc has given a pilot order for a reboot
of the 90 series
um
it'll be written and executive produced
by the guys who do la brea which is a
big giant hit for the nbc um stephen
lillian and brian windbrant
um
question yes does scott bakula play dean
stock what's his name uh
what was his character's name
um i forget
oh wait hold on
[ __ ] no it's not in this news sam
sam beckett was was bakula
sam was bakula yeah is the other guy was
it frank
i feel like i feel like we could get
this
out
of this hard with al
um thank you chad yes appreciate it
does scott bakula play out
he should
right
but
bakula is not attached to a prize's role
or produced the new quantum leap series
but is aware of the reboot has had
conversations about potentially getting
involved
so i mean you want to make both fan
bases happy old and new
hire him to play out true that's my
casting bit of brilliance right there
yeah unless the show is about finding
sam beckett and so then you don't need
him until season three or four
um at which point you get him for one or
two episodes so he doesn't violate oh
and so it's actually tied into the old
one and [ __ ] yeah it's a deep
continuation that's better that is way
better
i would like that more like sam becca
got lost he quantum leaped into hell oh
[Music]
oh that's awesome um and there
[ __ ] he gets out of hell and just
when he thinks he's safe the god khan
shu is there and he's like i will make
you my fist
fisticus
can't believe we're going to see that
anyway yes um all right quantum leap i'm
there good prayer
[ __ ] it i i'm more genre give it to me
um
john diggle played by david ramsey who
had been a fixture of the arrowverse
seems to be getting a new television
show long rumored to be the green
lantern in that world they were seemed
like they were always kind of hinting or
building toward that which i think they
they they nudged right up against in the
sort of arrow finale
where i think he did get himself a ring
of sorts
is he getting is he playing diggle in
this new thing
he is playing diggle in this thing he uh
in the new series uh years after
fighting alongside mass heroes john
diggle embarks on a new mission to
recruit five young metahumans to live
undercover as freshmen in a prestigious
university there he will oversee their
education and train them to become the
heroes of tomorrow
uh sidebar yes
you know i know i'm always told by
people stop [ __ ] reading chat and
giving voices to blah blah but
just to show you like how [ __ ]
spoiled everybody is
frankie asked why is kevin not watching
the most recent episodes of disney and
marvel tv shows talking about what
happened last week makes this talk stale
and less interesting
i was talking about [ __ ] peacemaker
and i got yelled at
we're talking about a thing that nobody
else saw
what marvel show have i not watched that
i'm not talking about
and the only [ __ ] thing i didn't see
yet is the episode of [ __ ] boba fett
which just literally dropped last night
and the boys did talk a little bit about
it no
so
hey
frankie
relax yeah what the [ __ ] frankie frankie
say relax frankie
come on baby
i mean
uh so yes this new this new show which i
think what's the name of this bad boy
justice u
period
great idea and what a great idea to give
him his own [ __ ] show dude's been in
the arrowverse since it [ __ ] happened
like
and he's a constant and he's shown up in
all the crossovers and some of the other
shows and he's a lovely dude um [ __ ]
i'm all for it so he's playing diggle
and what he's gonna like train other
heroes he's training five young meta
humans
as their sort of teacher slash counselor
as they're in a prestigious university
uh pause i thought there was a news
story i read last week about how cw's up
for sale
you know such things happen but until it
sells
they're still making shows
so they're just gonna pretend it's like
business as usual until somebody's like
i'm buying it and turn it into an
all-news station i don't give a [ __ ]
about superheroes because that's the
article i read yep
but until again it's always going to
take years for a deal that big to go
down so like until that happens and it
may not happen but until it does
we keep on making the [ __ ] donuts
uh what young heroes they're gonna be
they did not they were very coy about
one of the young heroes
[ __ ]
it's all i wanted to know
yes but it was coming from uh from our
our friend more yours than mine greg
berlanti um
as well as i don't know he's my friend
he was nice to me but i think he's more
my employer from time to time than my
friend um but if he was my friend i'd be
like greg can you give me like three
shows
i want more shows you have so many just
give me [ __ ] can i have one it'd be
like raising arizona that he's got more
than he can handle
um yeah so i want me a show huh
yeah berlanti uh superman and lois uh
co-executive producer michael narducci
and grey's anatomy producer zowan clack
are bringing us
this particular televised entertainment
i'm rooting for him
excellent
were you a real steel fan do you
remember that movie sean levy hugh
jackman yeah with you where he were the
rock'em sock'em robots movie yep
it was a good watch yeah because
ultimately it was a father-son movie and
so there was a lot of heart and emotion
to it and the robot
you know he was a robot but still he was
kind of human and [ __ ] yeah no i liked
it yeah disney plus is developing a
series based on said movie
um
unclear whether or not hugh jackman will
reprise his role
as the x-boxer did he find didn't they
if i remember that movie didn't they
find that robot and clean him up and
yeah it was a whole like there's a you
know giant robot boxing
you know [ __ ] monopoly going on and
they find this this busted up robot in a
junkyard and they fix it up and they
makes to run the title but of course
it's not about the winning it's about
the father and son being you know
drawn together as a unit again
um but yeah they're apparently they got
eyes on making that a tv show so good
for them i like that movie like it's one
of those didn't expect to like this
movie as much as i do but [ __ ] it okay
agreed i i remember when i saw the
trailer i was like rock em sock em
robots and then i saw the movie and i
was like
i wish i could call my dad and hug him
but he's dead i love you so much
the robot did it
let me tell you something this movie
better not be somebody finding him in
another garbage pit because all that's
that's like [ __ ] after the human
adventure with hugh grant he was like
let's throw this [ __ ] thing out yeah
i got my dad back bet peace out robot
like how cruel
um what other news hi the hip mark have
you seen the tragedy macbeth yet by uh
yes the cohen brother i did it would
have been on one of the lists i was
supposed to talk about but alas [ __ ]
fantastic it's so good
like
it has it gives me those feels of both
like orson welles
and like 60 star trek
yeah in the like
like that's very spartan very
gm geometrical
yeah that's the word
um very like
[ __ ] german expressionist
but
you know the business's finest actors
doing shakespeare
and it's also relevant to this
discussion because it's got witches in
it [ __ ] it which is a magic show
there's witches in it and [ __ ] yeah it's
good it's worth watching if you got
apple tv it's on apple tv
uh pricking up my thumbs something
wicked this way come on it was real i
loved how they did the cauldron scene
yeah it was great like the staging of it
is beautiful as well um he adapts it
from was it ethan or joel cohen which
cohen is joel
he adapts it of course from shakespeare
but like he you know he's a filmmaker as
well and it's shot
beautifully yeah um but in a very
not proscinium style but an almost
theatrical style it's got hints of the
seventh
seal too like you know it's [ __ ]
gorgeous man but at the end of the day
it's shakespeare and
you know
it takes a minute
for a year to get used to it but it's
like some of the most beautiful flowery
[ __ ] anyone's ever [ __ ] written god
takes 28 words to say you know what
could be said in two
and and you're you're all the better
forward all the smarter for it
yeah i think it was um
franklin leonard of the blacklist
on twitter said something to the effect
of i sure do wish that apple would just
commit to making all of shakespeare's
library this way like find great
filmmakers here's 50 million dollars go
make me a [ __ ] shakespeare movie just
so that it exists as a resource for
people like the finest actor is working
the finest director is working adapt
this stuff make them accessible
and make it part of the american
curriculum that you know granted you've
got to have apple tv but make it
available to schools one more uh it must
be directed by
joel cohen
another caller he did a cohen yeah any
cohen either of them will do because
that was such a [ __ ] beautiful
rendition you know and like let him do
it the same way each and every time so
it's [ __ ] uniform and whatnot same
kind of spartan sets high angles [ __ ]
brilliant actors and [ __ ]
and no no color man like
boy that [ __ ] was powerful black and
white
it was but i would also
like i would be here for like shonda
rhimes as romeo and juliet
i mean don't you get that every week on
[ __ ] grey's anatomy
yeah but it's not romeo and juliet
though
true
you're gonna do the iambic pentameter
and [ __ ] like oh yeah you would have to
like that's the that would be the play
by the rules like the new version of
dogma 95 or whatever
you got to shoot it like this and you
got to use the language you can't
colloquialize it you got to play it
yeah reading it from the book that'd be
cool you know like that's the reason why
i like baz luhrmann's romeo and juliet
like yes it does take a couple of
liberties with the language but
it's that [ __ ] text
and it's just great actors setting it in
a different milieu that somehow does
contemporize it while retaining its
classic nature like some
some ongoing initiative that gives you
shakespeare done that way would be
amazing but agreed that is another humor
there we're just wish casting now aren't
we give it to us give it to us i want
steven soderbergh
dude what would he do
what's a good soda break one
a midsummer night's dream
or or
guillermo gama de toro for midsummer
night's dream we've seen that though
you know
yeah but
i don't know
he was he that's the one guy who might
be constrained
by it's summer night's dream his
imagination is way bigger than even
chicks or the tempest give him the
tempest
yeah
um all right so yeah kids
tragedy macbeth it's it's under two
hours breezy watch wonderful indeed um
okay there was a bunch of star trek news
that dropped
i think yesterday
about renewals and release dates but
star trek discovery has been renewed to
her fifth season
and the fourth season premieres on
thursday the 10th
season two of star trek picard which i
worked on um will premiere on thursday
march 3rd
and it's currently in production for its
previously known third season star trek
strange new worlds has already been
renewed for a second season even before
season one debuted
which happens on may 5th
and then lower decks the two animated
programs lower decks and prodigy
will return
um let me see
both later in 2022
it's a good time to be a star trek fan
if you're that person
i respect
star trek's uh
existence
and i'm very picky very very choosy with
my star treks um but i'm happy that
there's that much star trek going on
for all the trekkies out there indeed
the people they love it
um and the last new story is you know
it's not quite genre but it feels like
it was up our alley
daniel radcliffe
has been tapped to play musician weird
al yankovic
in weird the ayakovic story
for roku for roku um and it's coming
from funny or die but it'll stream
exclusively on the roku channel he seems
like he's got a good sense of humor that
kid he does that other comedy show right
like um can't they [ __ ] his name in that
thing it's on tbs yeah the historical
one yeah
but yeah that's that's cool man i mean
i'm trying to think does he look like
him at all
you know
isn't and is weird al tall
weirdo is freakishly tall i think i
always thought he was like six foot two
six foot three and danny radcliffe is
not that he's not that high but then
again like in a world of [ __ ] and
house of gucci they made jared leto look
like jared leto's [ __ ] grandfather
i guess you know they can make him look
tall
um the quote from uh from weird al
is one of my favorite like [ __ ]
press quotes that appear in stories like
this
when my last movie uhf came out in 1989
i made a solemn vow to my fans that
would release a major motion picture
every 33 years like clockwork
very happy to say we're on schedule
and i'm thrilled that demi radcliffe
will be portraying me in the film i have
no doubt whatsoever that this is the few
the role future generations will
remember him for
that's that's terrible
i'm not surprised that weird ali
yankovic said something funny but uh
that is that's good that's that's good
you know
like can we get a quote from you usually
the quote so i look forward to this and
[ __ ] that's funny that's clever [ __ ]
indeed um that's the names my friend
that's all the news we got that's all
the news we got mark bernardin gave you
the news ladies and gentlemen uh let us
pray no let us go
to q a we have no second sponsor except
for here uh jay and silentbob.com for
all you need you want one of these silly
hats go to janesalembob.com
uh you want to see me
five mornings a week doing a show called
waken bake where i just ramble
join that kevin smith club at that
kevinsmithclub.com there there's our
middle of the show sponsor you got
something you want to sell there mark i
don't at all go but when when critical
roll drops on the amazons by all means
check it out if you're the kind of
person who wants to hear from many
people running the dnd campaign but see
it online i made it all pretty liked by
the good folks at titan mouse
check it out
i know
uh
hey banff man did you pop in and then
like go running away when i started
selling
i was just gonna
i was gonna talk about something else
that looked like one of those moves
where he's like i'm gonna be on camera
for that commercial i don't know
i was looking to see if i had um
a uh
my camera just fell um
i was looking to see if i had a sorry
earthquake
oh my god like you just shattered the
magic i always thought you were in a
city
um
i'd see if i had
a website that i could pull up to that's
why i disappeared
folks in chat uh are asking and it's
only because
we it happened last week or whatever we
were off but
uh yes of course nobody wanted to bring
the show down but the great bob saget
passed away
i only crossed over with him once
somewhere i was leaving a place and
coming in and
he he was so nice and polite and stuff
um
you know i don't know why i expect
anything less because he was always that
guy on tv
but um i guess because he was so famous
i thought he would be
you know like yeah whatever but he was
like hey man how are you big fan blah
blah blah
um
so uh i don't have much experience with
him but everybody i know who knew him
absolutely [ __ ] adored him as a human
being he was a funny dude my first
exposure to bob saget
wasn't you know full house or [ __ ]
you know america's funniest home videos
it was an episode of bosom buddies
in which uh uh
uh the character isabelle
wanted to sing
and her friends were backup singers and
uh tom hanks character kip
uh was introducing
her each time and she there was a comic
who was opening for her
and she kept the gag was she kept like
getting up to sing but she couldn't sing
she was too embarrassed and she'd run
off stage so they had to keep bringing
the comic up and when he brought the
comic up at first tom hanks was like
everybody give it up for the comic man
he's
really selling them and by the end he
was just like
the comic yeah
give it up for him um and he was funny
even as playing a stand-up comic
um generally speaking like when they
depict stand-up comedy and tv and movies
not always that funny he was actually
funny and i remember like as a young kid
he popped up on my radar then years
later
when he was on
full house i was like holy [ __ ] that's
the guy from [ __ ] buddies
uh you got any bob saget stories
i don't i've never met him
um
i i just always appreciated
the fact that you know my first
introduction to him was on full house
which i was not a you know a frequent
watcher of but tgif sometimes you're
gonna [ __ ] watch some [ __ ] on tv
um so i guess i've seen you know a dozen
episodes of that show over the years
but then to also learn that he was both
an incredibly filthy stand-up comedian
who um
who when i saw his turn in the
aristocrats which was hilarious right
um
but then to discover you know both
before he passed and then after that he
was also like the nicest man in the
world
um
a directory also he directed dirty work
yeah you know and so to see
to see a guy be
sort of all of those things
um
is always just kind of interesting and
and heartening that you can you can do
the work that you love you can
be the person you need to be
for the the people who are you know
employing you but also still be yourself
and and retain that throughout your
career so
rest in peace bob saget rest in power
bob saget 65. when he passed
um i'd read something i don't know if
they ever released his cause of death
official but somebody had speculated it
was a hard thing and that scared the
[ __ ] out of me and made me start hiking
running again and today was my 10th day
of hiking runyon canyon four miles from
door to door so
um
you know
even though i didn't know him i
benefited
uh from his example bob made me get up
and go walking
rest in power bob thank you bob
uh okay
what about betty white did we not talk
about betty white we did
i thought we did that last episode yeah
but if not
[ __ ] world is a darker place without
betty white man like
i think we talked about her but we did
we all love betty white and we miss her
as
well um
everyone
people like has everyone forgotten bob
and half baked says doom smith's like
pad channel no we just didn't list
everything that bob did we we went for
the two most prominent
you know and we didn't even mention how
i met your mother for heaven's sakes he
was the [ __ ] voice of of the narrator
the whole time so
bob had a huge career uh indeed
bob saget you'll be missed like from all
by all reports one of the good guys
sad that he's gone um after a show too
yeah
what he loved and he went to sleep and
that was that so i mean it sucks to pass
but
you know it's he didn't he didn't die
doing what he loved but pretty damn
close so
they're you know if you have to leave
this world leave this world after you've
done something you [ __ ] love
doing
you know
my dad died that way
we took him out to eat at morton's
steakhouse he had a [ __ ] filet mignon
big piece of cheap two pieces of
cheesecake and he was drinking
manhattans all night and he passed away
a couple hours later and [ __ ]
um you know sad uh he had all sorts of
conditions he's had heart attacks
strokes he was diabetic and [ __ ]
but uh he was surrounded by
his family like his wife was there and
me and my wife jennifer were there
virginia my sister and her husband
eric was there and my brother was there
but his husband jerry was back in
florida so there's my dad like
surrounded by his kids and seeing how
happy they've all turned out in life and
[ __ ] eating steak and we were all
trying to be entertaining and [ __ ] so
he was always silent bob just quietly
sitting off to the side observing until
he had the funny thing to say and [ __ ]
that whole night he was sitting there
[ __ ] eating filet mignon and [ __ ]
grabbing another piece of cheesecake and
ordering another manhattan while
everybody else was talking he was using
that as a distraction from my mother
she's just like
isn't the boy funny give me another
manhattan
oh
he died the next day i got a call from
my my brother he said we were in
philadelphia the wizard comic con
and uh
i uh went uh my brother called me he's
like you gotta come down to the hospital
dad's in the hospital and you know that
wasn't
a rare thing he was in poor health so
he's in that hospitals my whole [ __ ]
life
so i was like oh what for this time and
my brother goes get down here now and he
hangs up and so he sounded serious and i
went down there and my dad had like he'd
passed away he was he was passed away
died screaming i've told this story many
times but uh
point being
the end came from my dad
and it sucked and he wasn't all that old
he was 67 and [ __ ]
but
the night
before like if that was your last night
on [ __ ] earth
and you're hanging out with your family
this family that you [ __ ] put
together from scratch most of the
[ __ ] people at the table the majority
of them came out of your balls
like
you know [ __ ] and everyone doing well
and happy and [ __ ] having a good time
we ate at a nice place and [ __ ] like
that like
he was a he went to bed satisfied that
night he was a happy camper mom said and
then of course he woke up in the middle
of the night and [ __ ] died horribly
but
but still
like
you know i don't know
if it's the same for bob but like he's
seen we just saw an interview he did on
like instagram before he passed away
where he talked about
like loving doing the show he had just
done and being back on the road and
stuff like that so in a world where it's
like
something bad happens and people die
it sounds like you know he wasn't with
his family that would have made it way
better of course but
at least
the night before he left this best of
all possible worlds he was doing
something that
that truly meant something to him like
if you heard him talk about comedy it
wasn't just like that pays the bills it
was about [ __ ] spreading joy for the
guy
so
you know
hopefully that's a
a good sign right that like he
he you know we don't know what happened
but like
we always like to think of people dying
in their sleep fairly peacefully and
stuff like that
uh better than dying any number of other
ways and it sounds like he earned it man
it sounds like he was a good guy who who
earned that kind of
like hey my last night was a hell of a
night that's what i think about my
father all the time and like
bums me out that he died
uh but
if you gotta go
like
he [ __ ] went
feeling pretty damn good about
everything what and something that he
had something to do with right like
anything yes rest in peace bob saget
rest in power
indeed we missed man we need more
[ __ ] funny people in this world man
and a fearless comedian too most people
of course know him from like you know
[ __ ] full house and know him from
america's funniest home videos but like
anybody that watched those roasts or
anybody who saw comedy real comedy like
he worked [ __ ] blue as they used to
say back in the day he was like a dirty
funny [ __ ] comic like went for it
um
but
super sweet guy don't mean those two
things can't be the same you could be a
foul-mouthed individual and still be
very sweet and good-natured i've spent
many years trying to prove that
um all right
jc
you said did you get something you
wanted to talk about before we got to
the q a um
i may be late to the game but didn't dc
i mean
i thought it was this past week but dc
released an official image of the
batgirl costume did you guys see that
yeah
yeah it's uh
i mean this was
i i had no interest in the batgirl uh
movie and then i saw this costume and i
was like oh my god
one more time the movie and not a series
yes for hbo max
it's an hbo max movie yeah this the
outfit looks [ __ ] dope she looks
great um
this is the girl who was in in the
heights i think is that who it was yeah
last name is grace remember her first
um that looks fantastic it looks like
the video and game incarnation of her or
like the one they did in
not batgirl year one but there was
another series it has a similar look it
it looks enough like the
adam west batman for me to to
just i'm i'm full in
yes
the batman 66 version of the yvonne
crabber batgirl
which for like you know for all sense of
purposes
pop culturally speaking
is probably the bat girl
most people have in their head
of a certain age when you say the word
batgirl like it's not like batgirl has
had many movies and many tv shows um
this is going to be huge for that
character man
good friends and i think they're
bringing michael keaton back for that
too right yeah yeah yeah don't don't
careful how often you throw around
michael i got yelled at by the internet
for being excited about michael keaton
and now i have to [ __ ] ameliorate it
every time i bring it up
yeah the idea that i heard and you know
or i got from what they've been saying
is
they're doing a batman begins
but with batgirl and
batman is going to be old
bruce wayne batman who's kind of a
mentor or something if that's the movie
i'm all in for it if that's not the
movie i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm still in for it
um all right all right
cool
uh with qa
is that where we're at wait a second
this is
krasnostein
in chat
asks a legitimate question why are
people not caring about tom cruise in
doctor strange too
there are rumors going around that tom
cruise
uh
spoilers this is on the internet and
again it could be like [ __ ] made up
and [ __ ] like that
but
there's a there was a rumor going around
that tom cruise
is
in uh
multiverse of madness and he's playing
an alternate version
of tony stark
i was so excited when i read that but i
read that like years ago too or
speculation or something like that with
like what if it was him because at one
point i guess they talked about tom
cruise being tony stark
i hope that rumor is true but we didn't
really talk about it because it's
a very unsubstantiated rumor
as
unsubstantiated as the other what was
the other big rumor about a marvel oh
[ __ ]
multiverse of madness
apparently like if this story is to
believe they're trying to outdo no way
home
and multiverse of madness may have a
huge
character appearance
you don't want to know but it was all
over the internet the other day
uh john krasinski
it's it's for some reason i i don't know
if it was a
some website rumor or some sort [ __ ] but
a lot of folks saying john krasinski
uh
appears in multiverse of madness as wait
for it
a alternate version of reed richards
now how do you show an alternate version
when we've never seen the real version
right
but
even if it's them going look he ain't
gonna be the real guy but like you all
wanted to see this so we're gonna
[ __ ] throw it in
what
what delightful fan service that is so
yes we tend not to
go deep on the [ __ ] that's like i heard
but like those two rumors cited me but
we mark
as as we say in the intro mark's an a
news man he's not a he's not a gossip
man
he's not rona barrett you're looking at
you're looking at jimmy breslin all my
references are wow thank you
it's not head of hopper you're looking
at no louella parsons
all right jc okay
uh
harvey glassman wanted to know if you
were to do an opening dance number for
your new show
what song would you choose
um
well i mean clerks 3 opens not with a
dance number but it opens with a musical
number kinda
um and it's uh
from uh the good
folks it's fellow new jerseyans my
chemical romance uh and it's their song
welcome to the black parade so when you
see the opening of the movie like that's
pretty damn close what i would get to
for
for a music it is a musical opening but
like obviously people aren't breaking
into song but
it gets close
um in terms of the spirit of the thing
so
that's gonna be my cheap dodgy answer
what about you mark that's a good cheap
dodgy answer um i don't know the thing
that i would do that has a musical
number as an opening sequence but
i have always and when i say always i
mean always
love the song groove is in the heart by
delight
because i feel like it's impossible to
hear that song and not want to dance a
little bit so it feels like the the
bridge the road you gotta cross to get
your main characters
hoofing it on stage
to that song is not as far
so yes
that's that's the move groove is in the
heart
um
i um at one point when we were working
on that show hollyweed i wanted to do an
opening sequence
that was not a choreographed dance but
more like a um
we're still allowed to reference the
cosby show right
i believe you can remember the cosby
show opening credits where everybody had
their own little dance thing
so we were going to do something like
that and the song that i wanted to use
was um
uh
uh
digital underground if you kiss me then
i'll kiss you back that's a good one
it's a great song
but if you hit me then i'll hit you back
um
all right
cool
two good answers to a strong question
we're we're coming out the gate
with strength ooh we're pushing strong
banff man is back to
uh digital puppets was asking
uh if you had to use animation to make a
sequel to an old movie what sequel do
you make
you're making your sequel as animated as
animated probably because the actors are
unavailable the og
but you want to keep it in the same
universe
okay
hmm
um
i mean i know there's like a star trek
cartoon but it's surprising to me that
they're not doing star trek with like
kirk and spock animated
you know the same way that like marvel
is
kind of doing x-men 92 or whatever the
[ __ ] right
they could totally do that but let me
think what movie oh [ __ ] jaws bro
cartoon
young captain quinn old captain quinn
make it anthology it's just all around
amity it involves those characters
sometimes you're off with
with matt hooper when he's like studying
oceanography and whatnot
when he's that incident he describes
about like you know a
[ __ ] shark ate his boat and [ __ ] like
that when he was a kid
um
quint's indianapolis story
animated
uh chief brody
working in manhattan
[ __ ] like the crime being too tough
in the 70s and he [ __ ] doesn't want
to be there anymore so that's why he
hightails it out to
to the shore
give me a jaws
animated series kids because you know
you don't have you only have one of
those actors left right like robert shaw
passed away a long time ago and mark
snyder passed away so you still have
richard dreyfuss
i don't know if lorraine gary's still
around but uh
you know that that would be my pick
it's a good one and of course the shark
itself
like [ __ ]
i just watch a cartoon about that
[ __ ] thing eating people
from its point of view
put a little hat on him a vest
[ __ ] show the it was made by frizz
feeling
it was the shark and he had the top hat
and he had the little
catfish
what was his name what was the name of
that show
that i don't remember
someone will tell us in chat hey
since our audience is com composed of
people as old as us
somebody will remember that cartoon it
was a frizz feeling the patty fritz
feeling the patty
animated thing circa pink panther
yeah from the same family
um i'm sorry i'm staring at check cause
i'm like they're always a little behind
us but somebody's gonna know the name of
this [ __ ] cartoon
not jabberwocky not chad or jaw
not jabber jaw jabber jaw was a hannah
barbara cartoon with a theme song they
call him jabba jabba jabba jabba jabba
jabba jaw he's the biggest meanest shock
you ever saw and he had the voice of
curly from the three stooges this was
not jabber jaws this was on a pink
panther show and
and uh
it was one of like a rotating three or
four cartoons
mr jaw it was part of the pink panther
show mr jaw
it wasn't mr jaws
mr josh shorts in 1976 yeah
t feeling present mr jaw mr jaw singular
yes single jumper funny he had a funny
voice like it was based on some other
you know media personality but he was
like i talk a lot of this yeah some
proper voice but he wore a vest and a
[ __ ] top hat
anyway
johnson
who's artie johnson that's right oh my
god that
that guy look right just there it is
that's it
my god my whole childhood is happening
right in front of my [ __ ] face i was
right about everything
except his name well done
uh what about you captain
um
i think
an animated sequel to a live action
movie
uh the whiz
i was gonna i was gonna go like just
straight up wizard of oz but i think i
think hey the wiz
really good music give me some of that
[ __ ] no doubt um you know a lot of that
if not most of that cast is no longer
with us i think but
donna ross is still kicking
but what is the um
what's the plot because they killed the
witch they did but if i remember
correctly there were lots of and by lots
i mean like four or five oz books
and so just
pick the second one which i have never
read but i know that there are sequels
oh my god that's right they have
built-in sequels duh
yeah there was a return to oz there was
anything i got back to oz there was
tick-tock
right you know like god emperor of oz
and then there was one that was just oz
and it was so weird because it was a lot
of guys in prison all the sudden whoo
i was like they're all wizards
except for that vernon schillinger guy
yeah
he's the cowardly lion
um yeah that's the one i would do
who is
let me collect some money to give you
for your whiz animated series that i
didn't know i wanted until this very
moment can you feel a friend rainy day
um all right there
banff man
we need one more question answer the e
these questions three
all right uh kevin kehoe kehoe
says
uh if your parents were marvel or dc
characters who would they be
so cast your parents is
superhero or
i guess characters they don't have to be
superheroes
um well i was going to cast him as
[ __ ]
superhero parents because i was going
like well
they're not
they're not thomas and martha wayne
because we were not wealthy at all we
were lower lower lower
lower middle class and [ __ ] if anything
we would have been the people robbing
the wanes in an alley so
i don't identify my parents grace and
don are not
thomas and martha
now they're not jonathan and martha
either
because traditionally
jonathan and martha while i was growing
up were look like grandparents
and my parents were never that old when
i was young uh also we weren't farmers
um
what did you see that name
yeah there was none of that
um
let me see
sorry people at home with your earphones
on i'm sure i just blew out your [ __ ]
canals
i wanna i wanna lean toward like matt
murdock because he's catholic but
but my dad was not a [ __ ] fighter
boxer um
and my dad if he was he would have
thrown the fight it would have been all
cool done
yeah he my dad would have been like i
got no problem with that what's the
purse done and done what i got to do
and then he would have told me he just
showed me the money he said son
being
being good doesn't matter
being good is a sucker's game yes
it was imparted life lessons about the
suckers
you're either you're either you know at
the table or you're on the table
[ __ ]
um you gotta take what you can when you
can while you can my dad sat me down
he's like it's it's tough on these
streets and i was like
island
they're bumpy they don't get paid very
well so they're tough on these streets
he could be you know he worked for the
post office so naturally he thought
differently um
wait where were we
you're still trying to figure out the
parents that you would have if they were
in common yeah yeah let's see let's see
kent and inza nelson
wow
thank you deep cuts pull let me tell you
why there is a version of dr fate
where kent and inza nelson were one
person
in the body of dr fate so he was both
male and female
that my parents were such a one unit
individual
they were one two-headed monster like
the ebersisk
they were the mom and dad they were two
individuals
under one helmet of power
that ruled my fate doctor
so
kent ninja nelson is who i'm gonna pick
they also i also love the incarnation
that uh it was a jam to mattis did
um
when he did his run on dr fate
uh with the cosmic smile it was so
deeply religious the story and whatnot
uh you know it didn't
as a guy who was still holding on to his
catholicism at that point it it did not
it didn't do anything to it allowed it
brought jesus into it which you know
most stories are like
if there's a god suddenly they were like
yeah man jesus like james mattis wasn't
scared to to reference jesus in the book
and in a non-selly way but like it
really worked with the story and tied
like dr fade in with other spirituality
it was [ __ ] dope man so
uh
my parents ken's kenton ins and nelson
none of the power the physical power
um and separately
i could have beat them both but together
under the helmet of naboo
oh [ __ ] they were they were a formidable
uh adversary nice and loving as well my
god my parents love the [ __ ] out of me
my mother still [ __ ] loves the [ __ ]
on me jake i was sending my pap mom a
package jake was bringing to fedex today
who works in the office
and um
he heard me talking to my mom getting an
address
and afterwards he was like that's
adorable i was like oh my god you have
no idea how much my mother loves me i i
was always the baby so my mother loved
me anyway but then i got [ __ ] famous
as well so i'm the miss baby
she goes into publix you know you know
she's they're like oh mrs smith how's
your son oh
you know he knows ben affleck [ __ ] like
that like shits she spends that kevin
smith's currency somewhere in this world
there's a 76 year old woman who throws
kevin smith's name around as if it
matters to anybody it's adorable
adorable the famous baby
i sent her she had a bad day
yesterday she was having like
some work done she has uh
uh a trailer that she refers to as her
villa
she [ __ ] loves it i was like ma like
yeah you're she you're coming from a
house but she's like oh but it's huge
and she likes living in the park
whatever [ __ ]
um
you know
some people are like aren't you scared
that people find out your mom lives in a
trailer park i'm like it's by choice bro
she's got
all the means in the world at her
disposal she don't want a [ __ ] house
she wants that
so it's manageable for it because you
can't get around that much anymore in
any event it's nice it's really [ __ ]
nice so
my mom was having some work done
on like her carport [ __ ]
roof
and the people working were putting a
[ __ ] post in the ground they hit the
[ __ ] water line
and shut the water down and the whole
development for like two days
and i was like ma are these people mad
at you she goes they're getting madder
so
she was like public enemy number one man
[ __ ] like the old lady that all the
other old ladies and old men
talk about and despise when they go pick
up their mail and [ __ ] so i felt bad for
her and so i like you know we live in a
world where you can
post mate your mother whatever you
[ __ ] want so i was like you know what
my mother loves like ever since i was a
kid crepes she'd go there was a place
called la crepe that she would take us
to fancy restaurant and [ __ ] she and
even if she goes to like [ __ ] ihop
she tries to get crepes and [ __ ] so i
found a crepes place like in florida not
too far from her she lives in like
central florida
and i had like [ __ ]
four orders of four different crepes
with ice cream and milkshakes brought to
her house late at night
and
like my father's been dead for close let
me see in two in 20 next year it'll be
20 years that my dad's been gone
so you know as far as i know my mom
don't have sex anymore she did with that
food my friend oh my god
he didn't even call me back like i got
scared like maybe the [ __ ] postmates
guy like knocked her over the head or
something like that because i was like
where's the [ __ ] call ma and even
though the postmates guy looked like so
mild-mannered i was just like yeah but
you watched dateline that's how it
happens and [ __ ] i was calling my mother
and [ __ ] and finally my mother called me
back and she was like i'm so sorry tiger
i'm just eating the crepes she was just
sitting there [ __ ] like column a
column b she called me up this morning
she's like i'm still eating them crepes
though
good job my mother my mother loves the
[ __ ] out of me
anyway over to you my friend who do you
see as your
parental heroes or in the marvel or dc
universe my comic book parents
are in in the in the continuity are not
parents at all
but they serve as such
um
they are
ben
and may parker
[Music]
a new york kid didn't grow up with a
whole lot
you know they raised they raised a good
boy
they raised a good boy so they seem to
know what they're about
and it shows you that it's it you know
that's a situation of nurture not nature
right i mean i know they're aunts and
uncles so there must be some
family tie but like that kid was not
raised by his parents he was raised by
two people like that neither of which is
his mom or dad and he turned into a fine
individual this fictional character
we're talking about like
he's a good boy he's a good he does good
in school he's got good grades [ __ ]
pull man like those are two
really wonderful parental role models
like and aunt may [ __ ]
you know she outlasted uncle ben
obviously indeed
but like still continues to be the
of the guiding voice of reason in
peter's life
yeah
sweet that's when you can like your
parents man like i know for some people
like this conversation is anathema or
something like that cause like i hate my
parents but
it's really nice when you can like the
people that [ __ ] brought you into the
world and [ __ ] raised you and [ __ ]
like that
as we see in peacemaker that's
you know what
if you can have that relationship all
the better watch episode four of
peacemaker the soon the moment it drops
tonight kids
uh or when you wake up in the morning it
is so [ __ ] beautifully done and it
touches on that very thing i don't want
to say more because i got yelled at by
somebody in chat who's like kevin's
spoiling everything when i wasn't don't
say anything yeah so i won't use the
word
um man two good answers to a pretty damn
good question well i like your answer
better than mine and [ __ ] although mine
was good mine was deep cuts
mine was clever but yours was smart
that's what they'll say they'll bury us
next to each other and they'll say here
lies clever here lies smart
clever did all right for himself smart
was an underachiever every [ __ ]
comes in that graveyard will be like he
wasn't so [ __ ] clever he's dead
and i'm like oh even in death
some [ __ ] saying some [ __ ] in the
comments you son of a [ __ ] god damn it
i'm gonna come out of the grave meet up
with jay fly around everywhere kick the
asses of young people
maybe don't make your gravestone a white
board
good idea man
it's actually a pretty good idea like
you know people would talk about that
they're like he he he said in his will
that he wanted his grave to have
whiteboard all over it so people could
write whatever the [ __ ] they wanted but
it could be right erased as well yes
leave some comments it's an edge of
sketch it'll go away hey let's shake it
click and subscribe if you like um
all right kids
that's it that's it that's all the show
agent zero one soul in chat says
uh peacemaker dies in episode four uh no
he doesn't spoilers that's not true yes
especially because we know we've got a
few more episodes to go
but there's some good [ __ ]
uh to watch
um
i got uh i'm getting lectured again ndls
music says i expect kevin to be fully up
to date
on book of boba next week lol i will be
i'm gonna go watch that now
it's there for you
it's gonna happen and guess what we can
talk about it next week we had so much
[ __ ] news this week man like
like nothing's gonna happen between now
and next week i'm sure so
next week we'll talk about mark's top
ten
talk about boca boba episode
four and five yeah if we go again on
wednesday
yeah if we're on a wednesday and we'll
talk about peacemaker as well word up
it's a code word ain't a promise it's a
[ __ ] threat that's what we do here
batman beyond threaten you with a good
time
uh
we uh thank you all for hanging out
tonight on what has now become a
three-hour
[ __ ] broadcast
indeed if we were on tv we'd be rich
dude from all the commercials
the network
would love us
except nobody would give us three hours
that's not at two o'clock in the morning
it's like hey guys by all means dorm
patrol it's a shame man right like
i i don't know the culture can sustain a
three-hour [ __ ] network
talk show where people just talk about
comics and pop culture and movies and tv
you should go buy networks be relegated
to a half an hour and called
entertainment tonight why can't it be
three hours i would watch a show like
that from eight o'clock to eleven
o'clock
you know what i don't need that i can
watch it on [ __ ] youtube that's what
youtube's for
there's they make dreams come true what
were you going to say baby i was going
to say don't they do that on the today
show in good morning america from like 5
a.m until noon now
and they're talking about stuff way less
interesting than us
way less interesting they talk about
news and [ __ ] issues and
[ __ ] politics i'm talking about
three hours prime time of like did you
see the [ __ ] moon night trailer
if you don't see it kids be the change
you want to see in life we ain't waiting
for somebody to offer us a three-hour
show where we talk about pop culture we
do it right [ __ ] here we do until we
buy the cw and then we'll do it there
yeah or until somebody buys a cw and
brings us on they say that it's gonna
become a news channel
probably not the news we want it to be
really couldn't it be three hours of cw
type news of like
[ __ ] guess who's crossing over this
week yeah i don't think so
uh did you have fun kids i know i did we
couldn't do any of this without the puss
person that puts us on the internet and
[ __ ]
and that is banff man himself mr jc
riefenberg reefenberger bird uh
reifenberg
is it really in german a german name if
it's
e you pronounce the second vowel so if
it was spelled i e
it would be
uh the e sound
[ __ ] hey man look at that we learned
i didn't know that yeah i'm saying that
actually the show has [ __ ] made you a
little bit smarter right there
not just clever but smart so wait it's
which letter comes first uh my last name
is r-e-i so it's pronounced reifenberg
so it's reifenberg but i always want to
say riefenberg because i'm like well
there's an e there
but you're right it's like
ei
not to use this as an example but
it's not rick it's reich so
it wouldn't be reef and burger wife and
bird we all learned something we all
learned something and nazis only came
into it like this much
i'm
um
the uh the other guy without whom there
is no show
that dude over there man
you know him
i know him we love him it's mr mark
bernardin giving thank you mark bernard
uh he's freakovid
so this i got super communities [ __ ]
look at that you get some you couldn't
catch your covet if you tried to give it
to him at this point so for small feet
we'll come over your house and lick
doorknobs show you how fearless he is
but i'll tell you right now he may lick
the doorknobs but he ain't gonna kiss
him he don't do that ain't nobody
kissing nobody here tonight
ladies and gentlemen that
is uh fat man
beyond for this week man i'm kevin smith
i am mark bernard tune in next week
same
fat time same fat channel spodcast.com
or youtube.com kevin smith jeff's kiss
everybody
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask kev anything every saga has a 10
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith